e
e e
all right we we have a one minute
warning here I think everyone's gathered
uh good morning it's uh 10:00 we're
going to go ahead and convene uh this uh
this morning session for uh division 3
uh this is a division work session
today's focus is a budget work session
on the division of economic stability we
have with us misss Karen Hebert and Mr
Nathan white um a little admin note just
to just to get it out there there's been
some discussion for the committee on
whether we really will meet on March
11th because that's a town meeting day
and and I think we're going to need to
uh go ahead and meet on that day and if
if you if you can't make that session
and it'll be online if you uh want to
think about the topic that we're
covering on the 11th and let us know uh
what issues or questions you may have we
can we can try to uh incorporate that Mr
chair can you remind us what the topic
is for the 11th I I don't remember what
March 11th is
okay you'll have uh the Veterans Home
followed by New Hampshire hospital Glen
Cliff home and Hamstead Hospital right
the D Direct Care providers for the most
part okay so with uh with that uh good
morning good morning I think we're ready
to hear what you want to share with
us good morning uh Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer with Department of
Health and Human Services uh this
morning we'll be starting on the
governor's operating budget page
866 and we will be working through page8
85 and then also before you you also
have the budget briefing book um and
consistent with the other areas we've
prepared a entry for each of the
accounting units in excess of a million
dollars on an annual basis and with that
said I will hand the presentation over
to
Karen good morning thank you my name is
Karen Hebert for the record uh director
for the division of economic stability
so thank you uh for allowing the time
for this uh presentation so the division
of economic
stability was established in
2018 there are several programs in this
particular division each of them has
their own objectives and methods to
accomplish those objectives as well as
performance metrics that are either
existing or in development so it's a
little difficult to present all of them
simultane ously as a unit uh and
sometimes difficult to see how they're
interrelated but hopefully through this
presentation you'll be able to uh
understand that more so the one thing
they do have in common however is this
Mission which is to advance the health
economic and social well-being of
individuals families and
communities turn to slide
three these are essentially the key
outcomes of this particular division so
the services from the division of
economic stability lead to Stronger
Financial Health and stability and or a
reduction and prevention of poverty and
the need for public
assistance it's important to note that
the services in this division can be
provided and are provided actually to
individuals from birth through the end
of
life there are some people who have
temporary needs While others have needs
from a particular point in time or for
the rest of their lives or through their
entire lifetime
rather so the programs provide what you
see in the slide includes access to
resources for Life Necessities like
Health Care housing utilities food child
care they provide assistance and support
to reach Independence and self
sufficiency the services we provide
include work programs and educational
opportunities for economic stability and
mobility and we have services that
promote responsible parenting and child
well-being can we uh pause there sure I
I I love these kinds of slides just to
do a really great bird's eye view of the
whole program um um I think I understand
then in
2017 the the funding for this overall
area was
Zero uh which begs the question uh what
will the total General funds be for the
first year of the new budget so the
programs existed prior to 2018 but they
were developed or created and an
established single division in 2018 so
previous to that they were kind of
spread out in different areas of the
department so this was a consolidation
then in 2018 that's correct okay are are
you still retroactively able to figure
out what the total cost of them were
before consolidation or upon
consolidation I'm I'd like to be able to
understand the rate of growth in this
area over the last six years that's
where I'm
going if if we're only looking for the
past six years then we have all that we
wouldn't have to do some type of
retroactive um like modified approach to
that because we we would have all those
years
budgeted okay I I don't I don't want to
do the extra work I'm just looking for a
good period where we can get a rate of
growth so so 2018 was the first year of
consolidation where there was a
Consolidated number yes so so so if you
were to look at the past couple of uh
operating budgets you you could see the
operating budget and you could pull the
spend and see that fairly easily okay so
I would like to know 2018 what the total
uh general fund spending was and then
what do you have u a summary already for
what this area is expected to spend in
the first year of the
budget for the for the entire division
yes for this page what what does this
page three cost sure
well so if you turn to page
885 of the governor's operating
budget you will see at the top there for
the division of economic stability
you'll see a summary of the federal
funds the general funds and the the
other funds in this
area and and just as a reminder the
adjusted authorized is not the budgeted
amount um it is typically always higher
than the actual budgeted amount that was
in 25
okay so so correct me if I'm wrong then
for
26 the total General funds is 76.6
million that is correct okay that's a
that's a good base and you you don't
happen to know what the uh comparable
number would be for 2018 in that line
not off the top of my head okay we'll
figure that out later um and then
looking at these four
blocks um are you able to
um either provide an estimate for how
much money what as a percentage maybe
would be easi as a percentage that would
go into funding these four areas of of
operation like for example services that
encourage responsible parenting and
child well-being it feels like it's
maybe 8% of your total General funds
budget and in um in 26 but that's a
guess sure and I think it would be
difficult to guess so these four blocks
essentially make up some of the
highlevel uh objectives rather or
mission of the division as a whole right
so there's more than one program that
could be accounted for in any one of
those blocks right so be a little tricky
and then when we look at trying to
determine percentages applied to things
like contracts I'm not looking for um
rocket science what I'm looking for is
we just said that we want to spend 76.6
million on the total you know and I'm
just trying to understand the context of
the size and scope of the operation by
knowing what percentage of the general
funds is likely to be consumed by each
of those four areas and I understand
that there's some slopping back and
forth between lines but I I but be this
this is such a great slide to give us an
initial picture of what you do and how
much money you spend in the aggregate it
would be even better if we could see a
kind of a breakdown in each of these
areas um and if if you don't want to do
that now if you can't do that now then
we could we could take that later but I
would like to stare at it for for a bit
and help determine that like now go
ahead and look at it or do you want to
come back this afternoon I think one one
thing that that maybe we can do uh Ju
Just on the fly as we go through this is
as we look at the accounting units it it
seems that that the the focus is General
funds so as we go through the accounting
units we can identify those areas that
are General funds because within within
the dees budget you do have a mix of of
100% Federal for certain class lines you
have 100% general for certain class
lines um and as we go through that we
can identify those areas and try to call
them back here uh to this larger box all
right that that'd be good that that's
the that's the top down breakdown that
would be helpful to understand what
we're trying to achieve here was there a
question over here yes yes go ahead uh
thank you chairman and uh thank you Miss
H uh representative Rich alveno from
chesher 9 uh I have a general top level
question what's a good working
definition of responsible
parenting can we just sck num
sure sorry I I just want us to do the
finance stuff and and to the extent that
we need to understand what they do so we
understand the numbers that would be
great but I don't want to like I'm fine
I can hold that be cha chasing side
issues I can hold that all right thank
you um unless you'd like to answer that
no I think that the answer will be
revealed uh when we get through some of
the the bureau's accounting units uh to
to understand the cont context of that
all right thank you thank
you so on slide four just basic gives
you a very basic organizational chart
for this particular division so with me
today I'm uh pleased uh for having the
division's deputy director uh Tina
Cabana who's in pink behind me uh and
several subject matter experts and high
level administrators from each area that
can assist me if needed
on Slide
Five I wanted to give you a bit of a
depiction of what our core values are in
this particular division uh I'm I'm
going to I'm just going to ask you to
keep moving uh till we get to numbers I
I I don't really want to spend a lot of
time on on on the the general overview
other than just we need to get down to
the
numbers so so the next SL slide you
start to have numbers outcomes and
results do you want to talk about the
numbers
there slide
six
sure so this is related to the Bureau of
Child Development and Head Start
collaboration it's a long
name this particular Bureau essentially
enables access to child care to support
child care support New Hampshire
businesses and economic development in
the state the services in this Bureau
depend on state and federal partnership
subsidy programs to make child care more
accessible for low and moderate F income
families to so that they can look for
employment attend school mental health
or substance misuse treatment or simply
go to
work children are eligible if they are
residents of New Hampshire and residing
with a parent caretaker
under 13 years of age or under 17 years
of age with a declared
disability so the outcomes in this
particular Bureau uh include uh a very
notable 45% increase in utilization of
what's known as the child care
scholarship that is the child care
assistance program also known as a child
care subsidy so this is really um
daycare costs right this is not a
scholarship as much much as it is we're
helping pay for daycare correct all
right I can't tell you where the name
scholarship came from but yes it's
beautiful marketing absolutely
yeah so 45% increase in the utilization
there which is pretty significant and
that's just in the last calendar year do
you happen to know what percentage of
daycare that the state is picking up are
we are we paying for 12% of our
population are we paying for 4 % so the
total general fund budget for this
particular area is 11 million uh I'd
have to do the math to get you the
percentage Yeah no I'm talking about the
percent of the population who are
beneficiaries of this program compared
to the total are are we subsidizing 10%
of our state it's probably around 15% of
children who are eligible for this
program
okay question represent tki thank you
for taking my question can we can you
just give me a little bit of an idea on
uh the federal poverty level if you I'm
assuming that's how you qualify for this
scholarship it's based on state median
income median inome up to 85% of State
median income thank you you're
welcome so one of the other fun
functions of this particular Bureau
includes uh improving quality with
activities under a quality rating and
Improvement system that the bureau
administers and manages it's known as
Granite steps for Quality uh so this is
a system that has been around for about
3 years now and at the moment has 160
providers now enrolled in that
particular program what what causes
somebody to be enrolled that we have
quality concern and we encourage them to
enroll yes we encourage licensed and
licensed exempt programs to enroll in
the quality activities we want to ensure
that the uh providers are um have
current and complete upto-date training
and professional development of them or
just the ones that we're concerned
about uh so the system is voluntary for
programs yeah first they need to meet
certain requirements under
administrative rules for licensing uh
which is a different area of the
department sure but uh on top of that we
are encouraging people and providing
them with opportunities for professional
development that can enhance their
quality so how many providers are there
in the state if we've got 160 in this
program how how many are not in this
program so there are 717 licensed
programs in the state
currently and and so so far it's been
strictly voluntary for a program to step
forward and say they want to participate
correct all right thank
you with equality uh includes
professional development opportunities
for
credentials there are many different
credentials for CH uh Child Care
Professionals uh and in the last year we
had 1,200 professionals who added a
credential to their individual
portfolio so we're not doing the
credentialing we're encouraging and
keeping track if they go get
credentialed somewhere else correct we
have uh we are able to link them with
the providers who give the credentialing
yeah so so what our function is is to
help professionals know that these
credentials are available and and ask
them to self-report if they get one
correct we issue the certificates for
the
credentialing okay thank you
mhm so you might be aware there have
been significant investments in child
care over the last few years in order to
stabilize and strengthen the industry in
New
Hampshire approximately $171 million of
uh that began in co uh the co era uh
that has been uh received by New
Hampshire specifically for child
care
okay so a lot of the Investments that
have been made have essentially paved
the way for further growth uh and
further uh success in strengthening
child care in the
state on slide seven there are a number
of examples I'm not going to go through
them in detail but these are just a few
examples of what we have accomplished
with some of the covid related funding
specifically for child care it includes
support for family child care providers
small businesses um various uh one
notable is the gorm Community Learning
Center expansion there is a lot of need
in the North country and very little
Supply uh so this was a really
significant uh event that uh was or
Center that was expanded and established
for the North country that's serving Now
49 Children and
Families you don't know what that costs
the state do you I do not
do you think there Mr White do you think
there's a separate line item for the
gorm Community Learning Center or is
that embedded in some other line item I
I I could look into it to identify which
class line it's included in I I suspect
it's a a 102 or a 74 but I just need to
look into it to find the exact class
line
okay I'm just trying trying to do what I
do barely consistency is to understand
the relationship between the costs and
the benefits it's good to see the
benefits I just need to see the costs
that are going with it because that
implies a return on taxpayer investment
sure I understand so I'm I throughout my
presentation I want to give you a base
of information so that you understand
why the costs are are
there do you have a question represent
just had a comment or I guess a question
in response to you talking about cost
and benefit I think there's a economic
benefit that results from this
programming um and I don't necessarily
know if you're the person to actually
give us those data points but I guess um
it's something that maybe as a division
we would need to look into on the
economic benefit of these programs yeah
so just to be clear I am when I say
benefits I mean it in a in a bigger
picture but because we're Finance I
would like to the extent possible to
pull out and segregate the financial
impacts from the other uh softer
benefits that's a longer description of
my saying I'm interested in cost and
benefits okay and I'm guess I'm just
commenting that I think there's a a
bigger net of benefits that I think some
of us take into consideration so sure
yeah this is
our uh representative priest
thank you Mr chairman and welcome back
and thank you for taking my question uh
on slide seven you've given us some uh
Matrix points on the Gotham Community
Learning Center and the out of state
time programs what about the quality
child care training do you have a number
of how many um facilities and you have
helped train uh to get their program up
to speed sure so this particular item is
a uh a project that was funded with arpa
child care funding okay uh so I can
provide you with the data with respect
to the outcomes of those projects uh
this was to give you a high level uh
understanding of of that and some of the
examples and I appreciate that and also
uh strengthening a family child care
would be another one I would like to get
some numbers on and can go back six
years or something like that as long as
you have the data um you don't have the
data you don't have the data but I I
don't these were very shortterm projects
covid funding covid related funding and
very shortterm like one year or less
okay okay great thank
you representative Daniels thank you uh
could you could you define what the
under quality chalky what the
environmental rating scales is H
it is a particular pathway for early
learning there are multiple different
Pathways and models that child care
providers can give to uh that they can
use within their um uh establishment
that is one of a couple of primary
models I can get you a little bit more
of a better description uh if you'd like
to have that if you could please I can
do that yes
slide eight essentially is to just give
you a bit of a visual this is the number
of children enrolled in the child care
scholarship program by
county and this is essentially one um
there are reasons why we're pursuing
more data collection with respect to the
scholarship program
so the the depiction here is probably
not surprising uh based on the number of
children involved in each of the
counties it looks like it's somewhat uh
based on the population of each region
but what we what we want to be able to
understand is that this could also be
based on
demand or availability and accessibility
of programs in these regions so this is
a start to understand further what
information we need to gain to assist
more families so the data data
collection here will be
important who who who gathers this data
that's is that a person in your division
or is that somebody shared across the
department so this this comes from our
New Hampshire connections information
system which is managed by this
Bureau wh which division manages
that this one
okay all
right so this this isn't
data that's
also pull
or P collected and and an analyzed by
the depart the um office of Health
Equity because because this this implies
that there may be an equity issue here
and I'm just curious where we're doing
data collection and Analysis and we're
trying to understand our demographics
and need it sounds like you're doing a
demographics and need assessment that's
separate and distin from what may be
getting done in other divisions we've
not yet brought the office of Health
Equity into an analysis but this is
where we ultimately want to go to be
able to identify First what are the data
points that we should be collecting for
the system and then conduct an analysis
of them okay what what's What's the
total number of children receiving
daycare
support that is uh 4,032 children as of
the end of January
okay thank you
welcome so slide nine is another map of
the state which is a little bit more
interesting uh is this a number of
licensed slots I want to say slots
that's essentially um a a space the CH a
child could
be taking in that particular
facility so slots among providers who
are participating in the child care
scholarship program not all providers
participate in this program so graming
zero
yes so this depicts very limited access
to and or supply of child care for
families with low or moderate incomes so
this essentially will help us strategize
around the use of the federal child care
Development Fund and how to increase
access represent priest thank you Mr
chairman and thank thank you for taking
my question um back to slide uh nine
again the
4,032 children are the children that
participates in your programs is that
correct that is the number of children
who we are paying for child care for
okay and do you know how what the need
is for the enti people that are coming
to you but you don't have the slots to
help subsidize their child care
uh so at this time we uh would still
have more utilization that could happen
with the Child Care Subsidy program so
if somebody were applied today for child
care they wouldn't be turned away it
would not be turned away correct not
today not today do you have that magic
number I do not you do not okay thank
you you're welcome
slide 10 uh we can get more into the
numbers that I think you are interested
in so for the first accounting unit this
is essentially the
operations of this particular
Bureau and it is uh briefing book is 878
if you're looking at that
um and since it's under $1 million in
funds uh it does not appear on the
budget briefing
book so this particular accounting Ute
is 100% federal
funds and this is the fund known as the
child care and Development Fund issued
by the administration for families and
children
the second accounting unit is
specifically for the uh employment Rel
it's also known as employment related
Child Care there's multiple names
referred to the Child Care Subsidy the
scholarship program it's all the same
thing uh but here in the budget we refer
to it as the employment related Child
Care representative
walner thank
you so when I'm looking at this I see on
um protective preventive Child Care was
in this
um area and
did notice when we were doing the
um budget last week and we were looking
at um the children and family area that
it had um it looked like it had
transferred over there yes yes that's
100% correct we we move those funds over
to DCF just to try to recognize those
costs in in the DCF realm okay I have
further question so will the providers
see any difference in the way that the
billing um is initiated or how they will
get paid now that it's moved over to
that other division could be more
streamlined just because less people are
involved in processing it okay great
thank
you uh
represent go ahead thank you Mr chairman
um so you mentioned a minute or so ago
that right now the utilization isn't
fully taken up what is impact in terms
of federal funding when not as many
people are taking scholarships as could
does the money not come in or does it
come in and and and remain with us until
such time as it needs to be used yeah we
have it available it comes in the form
of a block grant that we receive from
the federal government so we have that
available so we're
constantly uh evaluating the use of the
childcare fund for the Child Care
Subsidy uh and then with that fund we
are required to spend 9% of it on
quality
activities we're also required to spend
3% of it on activities that relate to
infants and
toddlers of from those reserves and then
five up to 5% for administrative cost so
from there we look at what's left over
essentially where we could would look to
pursue expanded services that would be
uh assisting quality or do we look to
assisting providers for the last uh few
years because utilization has been low
uh but now growing but while it was low
we were able to take those particular
dollars and distribute them to child
care providers for quality
purposes um represent nalco yes thank
you Mr chairman uh quick quick question
on the Rel where it says um Head Start
collaboration what what is that is Head
Start is a totally separate entity and
then they interface with your division
correct so Head Start collaborative is
essentially that so we don't manage Head
Start we don't oversee funding for it uh
it's essentially what it's called just a
collaborative that the department has
with the Head Start Association in New
Hampshire so that we're looking at
identifying what are the objectives that
we may have in common for Head Start and
child care in the State uh and really
participating in a lot of um uh
communication together building those
particular objectives and then ensuring
that we carry them out so we are we
receive a a small amount of money uh
$125,000 a year from the office of head
star federally that supports the
collaborative so we have one staff
person who works with the headart
association and the federal office of
Head Start to essentially look at the
objectives so that we are uh in
alignment with what the head Head Start
Association needs in New Hampshire okay
so just a quick one so so I take that to
mean that the funding covers our
expenses for the collaboration and
that's Federal money correct okay thank
you is it is it the case that on this
page 10 the only area where we're
spending any general funds of these five
topics is in the children develop Child
Development Area and that's uh almost 12
million in general
funds so yeah the general funds uh goes
towards the um uh employment related
child care okay so and that's in order
to meet uh required match ande for the
federal
funding O Okay so on that page the only
General funds is that in that one
area when you say the the page do you
mean the slide or I'm slide 10 okay so
the other general fund essentially is
the last one which is the childcare
Workforce fund this is 100 just 100%
General funds okay this is a requ a
requirement out of hb2 from this bium um
or the 2024 legislative session
essentially that we would uh we would
put this into the budget uh and it's
been identified as a prioritize
need I'm not done yet but U I'll come to
you in a second representative PR okay
so I'm on page
882 um and
so the general funds for this
area um Mr White is that is that the 11
.9 million
yes now this says it's 100% General
funds but there's some federal funds
associated with this area am I what am I
missing I'm I'm looking at the wrong
things so so what what you're looking at
there that that's the total for the
activity of child development of
41111 0 so that's the summary there of
the preceding accounting units that fall
within that activity
okay so so by us doing the child care
Workforce program that is not bringing
any any supplemental federal funds
correct right okay representative
priest thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my
question back on slide 10 um those
accounting units like Child Development
operations and child care development
quality assurance and head start our 100
% federal funds um as you know there's
reduction of funding going on in the
federal government and have you done any
scenarios what impact that would have on
these programs I mean the programs
couldn't be funded period I mean or if
they were partially funded and how many
people would be affected by that and
whether or not the state could pick up
and cover them and so I'm I'm interested
to what your thinking would be on that
so we're in communication with the
federal office of child care
regularly right now there really isn't
clear information over the uh of what's
expected for the future of this
particular fund there was a an
inquiry um that uh the U Administration
wants to know and understand what the
fund could be used for there is no
information yet I think they had like 90
days and this was a month ago to provide
that information to the administration
so there is no indication of anything
changing right now with this particular
fund so could it sure but at this time
we just don't have that
information what I would be interested
in again it goes along with um chairman
edwards's comments is just the number of
people and children that
you bet um you provide support for in
those three areas so that if we do see a
reduction in those areas we would have
come of an idea of how many
people would be affected by it and
whether or not and then would open up
the question of whether or not the state
would provide any funding and could help
in these areas so as of the end of
January there 4,032 children that are
being provided this service and that we
are paying for the majority of their
child care some of them do pay a parent
C share um but so there's 4,032 children
that if we lost the ccdf fund today
would not
receive funding to support their child
care uh there's no other source from the
state to fund them otherwise uh so I
guess that would be a question for uh
for you all uh to or a determination for
you all to make if there would be other
funds that would support this program so
so so representative priest what I would
propose is that um we we think of
questions like yours um as we don't know
what we don't know yet so what should we
be doing as division three I think as
division three when we see federal funds
budgeted uh we should probably just go
ahead and assume that the that funding
is going to come whether it's in a block
grant or a line item but just for our
purposes of putting the budget together
I believe we need to assume that the
federal funds are coming knowing that
we're only a step in this process the
Senate's going to get this in the back
half of this term and more will be known
at that point
yes uh just as a clarification Mr
chairman um I agree with that we should
be acting in what we know but I come
from a field of urban planning
environmental analysis where we look at
the reasonably worst case and I'm seeing
now on the federal level what the
reductions are
happening um to other areas and since
we're in the midst of reviewing the
budget of the governor um the department
and us should be thinking
about what will happen if let's say they
do away with the block
brants to two states and I know it's not
in our purview we should be just looking
at the numbers of Governor but it could
happen next week could it happen next
month uh in the midst of our final re
utilization and so so if they don't have
the idea I mean
we it would be great to have those
numbers and and that's my justification
for asking for this information okay I I
the the division three is on the line
for submitting u a budget proposal to
the full finance committee and in order
for us to keep moving in a fairly direct
manner I I I intend to not go into the
assumptions of what the feds may do or
may not do to your point though is if we
get information before we're done with
our work we should definitely consider
the impact but I I don't see us spending
a lot of time doing what if worst case
scenarios okay thank you yeah um go
ahead I I I think we're on slide 11
represent Waller go ahead we could just
go back to page 880
again 880 in the yes in the in the
budget
book so this is the 100 you're talking
about the the quality one yes okay 100%
Federal 100% Federal
I was wondering um on the line of grants
for public assistance and relief what
would I mean that's a large increase
from 5 million in uh 25 to
um 11 million in 26 and I was wondering
what what we're anticipating there I
mean it is all federal
and but I was wondering what we're
looking at there
yeah I have that was thank
you just wanted to get the dollars uh so
the um sure so for for uh class 74
grants for public assistance and relief
uh these essentially are uh a number of
different contracts that we will or have
or would continue to enter into that
provide quality activities and services
for child care
providers so it includes um uh web-
based health and safety
training uh it funds some of our uh it
funds our our data system New Hampshire
connections uh it funds professional
development activities it funds the
child care resource and referral program
which is significant uh that also
provides a number of professional
development opportunities including
Department of Labor apprenticeship ships
uh so that uh also includes uh the next
market rate survey that we will need to
do next year um and uh um uh also uh the
parent um information center family
voices for example um working with
families so that they have a voice in
this particular process about child care
in New
Hampshire
so it has gone it is going up
considerably um and I wondered is this
um are the f is the federal government
saying this is how we need to use these
additional federal funds correct we have
to meet the federal Benchmark of
providing or using at least 9% of the
funds for Quality 3% for infant toddler
and then uh at least 70% has to used for
direct care uh and then the balance is
basically some discretion over what we
can use and we typically do it to to
fund quality but where we continuously
evaluate that would be if we're looking
at the potential of any unspent funds we
don't want to leave any money on the
table or return it to the federal
government so there are time frames in
which we then need to obligate the
funding and would look to other quality
activities to support the providers
directly okay do you know and can
you can you tell me is the $1 million is
that actually
9% of no that's part of it that's part
of it um I uh I don't have that
breakdown right off because for some of
the contractors they provide
both activities for infants and toddlers
And also quality for all of the
population there serving okay great
thank you
sure uh representative
seaworth thank you Mr chairman I may
have gotten a little bit confused with
that I I thought where that question
might be going is what is the basis that
we think there is such a dramatic
increase in federal funding um coming
down the
pike just at the highest level so
essentially for the future uh we are
looking at the increase in
utilization and needing to monitor that
very closely uh where we ultimately will
need to consider bringing in tanif
funding to transfer into the child care
Development Fund to
support the utilization increase if the
trend continues to increase we want to
make sure these families are covered
with that particular
subsidy when that happens it essentially
increases the amount of money that to
meet that 9 and 3%
benchmarks thank you all
right so I think we're at 11
again so slide 11 I'll introduce the
Bureau of child support for you these
are Services for Families of children
whose parents or parent caretaker do not
reside in the same household together we
serve both the paying parent and the
receiving parent or
caretaker essentially this program is
there to engage and assist parents who
are willing and able or perhaps unable
to support their children financially
and when necessary we enforce the
responsibility with parents who are
unwilling to support their children
financially so child support obligations
are determined by the court so this
program works very closely with the
court system uh to uh uh establish legal
orders of support and enforce
them we use a federally certified
automated case management system Sy for
child support as a number of interfaces
including with new heights uh and a
number of federal interfaces as well so
is New Heights the it system that you
rely on no no this system is called the
New England Child Support Enforcement
system it's acronym is
Nexus there are a number of strategies
that we use uh and collaboration with
Community Partners to try to reduce
barriers of the paying parent when
they're not able to pay we use our
Family Resource Centers to assist with
that we also use a a tiny Grant known as
the access and visitation Grant to work
with parents who are in dispute over
parenting or uh uh visitation
scheduling uh we also collaborate and
I'll talk later about the Bureau of
Employment supports with respect to work
programs and what they can do to support
the paying parents who need that kind of
support to find employment to pay for uh
the supporting their
children this Bureau essentially
believes in the responsibility of
parents to financially support their
children so we aim for quality service
and help those parents so so is that the
agency income the 1. 1855 that's that's
money is coming from
parents I think that's on uh page 80 83
estimated source of funds for Child
Support Services Agency income is 1.
million no th those are incentive
dollars that we receive incentive
dollars incentive
funds the federal government award
towards incentive funding based on
performance measures there are four key
performance uh indicators that then
determine based on the performance how
much should be awarded in incentive
funds the incentive is to do well in
performance so there's a range if we
performed poorly we'd get zero and if we
performed great we'd get much more
something like that correct we typically
earn about $2 million a year in
incentive fundings are we maxing out the
incentive or we in the midle range of
the incentive we we
uh it so the calculation for that uh is
also based on collections so I wouldn't
say we're maxed out um I'd have to C do
the calculation for
that would you give us a b are we doing
okay or we are we not or are we just
leaving a lot of money on the table here
I I might give us an A or a B I think
that we um
are doing well in collections the dollar
amount we collect however is based on
what's court ordered so if you have a
court order of $50 and we collect $50
that's a huge difference versus
collecting say $1,000 a week that might
be ordered for somebody else so the
collections are is a little bit um uh
varies uh greatly year toe uh but the
performance metrics we have to meet
certain percentages in how much we are
able to collect how much we are able to
how many court orders we're able to
establish in out of the entire case load
universe so so there's 126 people that
work in this area uh what how many of
them are working on trying to drive up
our rate of collections I would have to
give you a percentage but it's the
majority of them majority of Staff
include those who are working in the
district offices as child support
officers or case technicians that meet
directly with clients to establish and
enforce the support orders okay so
between 60 and 70 of them are working
on okay all
right so if you look at the at the
outcomes of approximately only 28,000
families are served
annually this last year we collected $78
million this is private funding uh
private money rather uh that were uh was
collected for families this essentially
helps them to be self-sufficient
stabilize them uh and uh need less
Public Assistance if
any but not only is this a cost
avoidance program it's also a cost
recovery program so we recovered out of
our collections last year $4.8 million
specifically for tent to offset tan of
expenditures what happens is that we
have families when you receive the
temporary assistance for needy families
uh benefit it's an assistance cash
assistance program which I'll talk about
more later on but when you have a family
who is receiving the that tan of cash
benefit they are required by regulation
to cooperate with the child support
program to pursue child support from the
other parent um to help offset some of
those tanif
expenditures so when somebody is
receiving the tanif benefit anything
that we collect for child support during
that time is retained by the
state we never keep more than we receive
that doesn't happen very often but when
we uh so when we retain the tan of
benefit the state retains a share of
that benefit which is which goes towards
tan ofe maintenance of effort the other
percentage is sent to the federal
government sounds like a lot of
accounting so this is this anara where
we got any waivers in to try to block
grant and streamline this process that
that that sounds very complicated like
we're spending a bunch of time and
effort in just doing the accounting for
this so the the this is where I think
the it system comes into play there the
uh Nexus system the the automated case
management system because we have set
within that system uh the the rules for
distribution so our system interfaces
with new heights and knows when somebody
is receiving tanif and when they're not
and then it knows what to do with the
collections that come in while they're
on TANF it knows what to do with the
collections that come in after they're
no longer on TANF it's a very
sophisticated system uh it takes care of
that distribution thank you you
welcome represent thank you Mr chairman
a couple of quick questions so the
28,000 that's that the trend on that has
been what over the last couple of years
up down um uh over the last couple of
years it's been declined it's it's
declining and same for the 78 million
that that would have declined with that
no
actually so that trend is
looks the the the trend in New in for
New Hampshire uh has varied
significantly over the last decade or so
so there has been a decline in case load
uh since about 2019
um but we still seem to be collecting
approximately the same amount um so in
uh 2011 for example for uh we collected
83.9 million in 2023 it was
72.8 um
so but the thing to keep in mind with
the correlation with collections is that
all orders are not
equal so you could have a higher number
of orders for a lower amount than you
did last year um but we the those the
dollars are counted nonetheless so it's
not a uh it's not really something you
can match year to year because that
influences the numbers greatly thank you
you're welcome now now is it is it the
case
where it the system is set up so that
every parent who's ordered to make a
child support payment that that payment
must go to the state and the state
redistributes it is is is that this
setup uh almost so every parent who is
ordered by the court to pay child
support is not necessarily a parent or a
family who has applied for our
services so we have families who are not
recipients of tanif who don't apply for
services at voluntary they don't have to
use Services of the state many of them
do for a number of reasons so you have
to apply for services this is not an
eligibility program okay so it's not the
case that every collection has to go to
the state correct however with respect
to uh any if you've got parents who are
not going through the state who want to
uh set up payments by way of a wage
garnishment
those are required by law to go through
the state's dispersement unit which is
managed by the child support program if
you have parent a voluntarily paying
parent B and writing a check every month
then and they're reliable then that the
state has nothing to do with that
correct all
right thank you you're welcome
so we could go to slide 12 and look at
the accounting unit okay I I think we
could go to 13 myself because we've sort
of been talking about these
items we haven't talked about access and
visitation but that's 100% Federal with
no no
Personnel correct so let's go to 13
so slide 13 essentially introduces the
Bureau of family assistance starting
with the director's
office the Bureau of family assistance
is actually made up of two large Parts
one of them uh uh oversees the
administration of business and policy
over Federal and State financial
assistance programs the other one is a
different uh a different group uh that
we will talk about um later uh but this
one specifically focuses in on the
business and policy side of the house so
to speak so this particular uh uh part
of the bureau oversees programs like the
supplemental nutrition uh assistance
program known as snap it oversees the
administ ministration for the temporary
assistance for needy families referred
to as tanif as I've been talking about
and also multiple State supplemental
programs uh that are state funded
including
APD um you'll see in the block on the
right this gives you the count of
persons as of the end of January who
were in those programs I realize that
those are acronyms I'm going to give you
the information for what they stand for
but essentially uh this is for our most
vulnerable populations who rely on us
for basic needs so the this the summer
EBT program for school kids uh does this
director's office manages that as part
of the snap program
correct and then just I I I I'm not sure
what page in the budget book I'm on I'm
just curious how many people are
employed by
this this director's
office there are 16 positions within the
director's office there's 14 classified
and two
unclassified and and what what I what
page number did you just uh so I was
looking at the Personnel count at the
bottom of page
okay thank
you so there are several accounting
units in this particular area uh but I
will certainly talk with you a bit about
the administration of the federal and
state Assistance programs I will also
talk with you about the work
requirements uh and programs that go
along with that uh and we can go through
those Associated budgets uh and then I
will dig into eligibility Services which
is the other side of the
house so the work of this particular
part of the bureau uh aims to achieve
these uh uh these needs that people are
individuals and families have because we
want um to provide a positive and valued
customer experience and a staff
experience that enables job
satisfaction slide 14 is a list of those
particular State supplemental programs
just so you have a bit about the uh what
defines those or description of each of
them and there is an accounting unit for
each
I'm curious
parenthetically in the box to the left
on page 13 you say basic needs and you
refer to shelter food clothing and
utilities m is there is there also
Transportation that's in there it's just
not item listed so in uh so programs
like Medicaid uh through the man manag
organizations do provide for
transportation for people okay but this
this family assistance program isn't U
driving sorry driving the
transportation
no representative priest thank you Mr
chairman back on page
14 um do you have the numbers of the
clients or people that you service
through the state supplemental
Assistance
programs yes so on on slide 13 in that
box on the lower right right those are
the current persons count of persons in
each of those programs as of January
31st okay so the aid for uh permanent
and totally disabled is
3,346 ETC okay great now this is just
for fiscal year 2024 right correct do
you have anything uh prior to those
years I do I can provide that to you
that would be great thank you um sure
also do you have any forecasting I know
we're not supposed to look at
forecasting can but we're looking at uh
I'm sorry let me clarify you can look at
forecasts what forecasts are great we
need to look at forecasts I'm just
saying we shouldn't be looking at things
that we have no control of and know you
know like the right right I agree um but
do you have any um forecast for 2026 and
2027 for these uh for these different
programs uh So based on your knowledge
right so the um the the budget amounts
for State fiscal years 26 and 27 were
determined by projections that we had
made um I can get you the specific
numbers if that's that would be great
thank you sure
okay you're doing great you're on page
14 or so and I think this is a 36 page
deck yes how do you think you're doing
when what's your estimated time of
arrival at this
point uh so I imagine we are going to go
into early afternoon okay so so just so
people listening to their gring stomachs
now we'll we'll take a recess at
12:00 sounds good so I wanted to provide
you with a bit of
in yes yeah thank you um quick question
on on third uh page 14 on the bottom
approximately what size of the
population on Refugee assistant
assistance are we currently
serving I have that
number I don't that doesn't show on page
13 right it's not a separate I have
those numbers bear with
me of course it's the last
page so as of January of
2025 there were uh 162 adults and 85
children receiving the C cash assistance
program for Refugee
cash is is that portion uh Federal uh
funded or we're doing that out of
General funds this is 100% federal funds
and you'll see if you look at the
revenue line in in the budget for the
accounting unit it's transferred from
the office of commissioner within o the
refugee Services account 729 sure sure I
just I just wanted to help put into
context what the impact of these numbers
are and if they're if they're still
ongoing with as Federal funding it's
less of a
problem less of a challenge is the right
word not
problem do you have a followup are you
okay okay representative walner did you
have a question oh no sorry all
right so I wanted to provide some
information specifically about the tanif
program uh that may be of interest to
you so the temporary assistance for
needy families program or the grant
rather it is a fixed block grant for
States uh and there are federally
defined specific purposes for the use of
this block grant uh there are four of
them I won't read them to you but that
they are listed on that slide so so my
focus on this is going to be on number
four I I think I think historically what
we found is that we've had no tanif
programs that meet item four to
encourage formation and maintenance of
two parent families that we've had no
programs and I encouraged you all to
take a look at the Nebraska program to
see what they are doing to help two
parent families and to come forward in
this budget cycle with your proposal on
how to do something similar do you have
a proposal on how we're going to uh
emulate the Nebraska program or some
other program to help two parent
families this cycle so we're looking at
uh Services through the Family Resource
Centers to be able to support to parent
families that meet these percent so
that's yes you do have a new program
that you're you're going to introduce in
this budget cycle uh it's essentially uh
funding the Family Resource Centers to
expand a lot of the work that they're
already doing uh in supporting to parent
families and other particular services
so I'm going to I can get into that a
little bit on the uh the next
slide but I I do want to just provide
some information about what uh makes up
the tan of uh
funding so on slide 15 it includes
federal funds from the block grant in an
amount of approximately $38 million
this These funds must be spent on tanif
eligible families that meets at least
one of the four
purposes the second part of the tanif
funding includes an annual state
maintenance of
effort that's $32 million of General
funds it's important to know that
whether the state spends $1 of the
federal funding or all of it the states
are required to uh spend the maintenance
of effort funding of 32
million the third part of the Tana of
funding uh would be referred to as the
tanif balance it's not additional
funding that comes in it's essentially a
balance of tanif funds uh that has not
yet been spent um so that includes the
current fiscal year uh amount as well
well represent yeah a quick question on
the the 32 million on the maintenance of
effort what what's that calculated off
of where does that number come from
sure sure is it a percentage of the of
what yeah go ahead the the the dollar
amount it's it's not a it's not a
percentage it's not based on a 5-year
history it's it's a fixed amount that's
been in place for decades um and and
it's important I I think just for for
new members of the committee to
recognize that we budget tanif across
the department um so that anybody
working on a tanif eligible tanif
related project can incur those costs
and so it one just just key thing that
I'd like to draw your attention to here
last bium um there was uh the the the
house added $3 million each year of
General funds to ensure that we a to hit
thate um One Challenge that we currently
have in the existing budget is we do
have about 74 positions that are
unfunded within this Division and so
those unfunded positions we will be
unable to earn M Moe um or or earn or
spend General funds towards towards that
match for any of those positions that
are funded with General funds um So
currently we are in the process of
looking at um what
what what amounts are we potentially
short to meet thee and we haven't made a
final determination on on that yet but
we should have one done here in the next
week or
two okay thank you so if we have to come
up with the 32 million and we have
vacant positions what happens to the 32
million do we do we just uh plow it down
to provide more programs to more um
clients so the money has to be spent and
um I I
think that's one potential way to do
that however that would require new
contracts and then those contracts would
have to be spent within the within the
applicable time period uh but that that
is certainly a potential
challenge okay qu question for you I I
actually have a question to
representative walner uh representative
walner so my memory is horrible the the
the the the the the transition house
down in Manchester that we went to go
visit Waypoint uh that is there anything
in Waypoint that would qualify
for under the tanif program do do you
know Waypoint well enough to know that
if we if we put money into Waypoint if
if that would count as
oure maybe so I would need to look at
ensuring that the purposes that uh you
know some of their particular programs
right you know and services right fit
any of the definitions of the purposes
of tanif it feels like it kind of does
because you got younger people there 18
to to
um that you know well depending on which
definition of child you use it some of
that can can count um
and and these These are kind of needy
families that need a place to go that's
number one it seems so um so if you've
not looked at Waypoint as a
potential uh
creditable expense i' I'd appreciate if
you would do
that okay and then represent
walner a couple weeks ago I think we we
heard in one of these meetings that
Waypoint did have some funding in the
budget and and you were going to try to
take a look into it would I know it's
off topic but I'm curious about what you
found on Waypoint we found and the
division as a whole we we heard it last
week it was in
the was it the full 500,000 a year yes
it was okay so so that's a nice chunk of
oure if we get credit
if you've never looked at it before
let's let's take a look at that happy to
so
yes thank you Mr chair yes last week
that's right it came up Waypoint is
funded on page
1012 and it's item
102 all right well if we're going to
spend that money let's get some extra
credit for it representative Daniels
thank you uh whereas Employment Security
does preparation for jobs and work it
can TANF money be be funneled over to
Employment Security so we're not
duplicating efforts I am going to talk
with you all about the Bureau of
Employment supports that we collaborate
with Employment Security specifically
for that purpose and yes it involves
Tanana funding thank
you represent priest thank you Mr
chairman just as a point of
clarification back on page uh is it 16
or 15 uh 15 I guess y um on thee if we
don't use the funding we lose it
right the the federal funds are carried
forward in in perpetuity um we we spend
the uh the oldest Grant first and then
we then go going forward and I think
what one important thing to understand
about thee that we haven't discussed yet
is if we don't spend oure then we will
see an equivalent reduction and we will
also see an equivalent penalty okay so
then the next year um you know then then
you're then you receive less funds and a
penalty so not only are you paying for
what you came up short in the prior year
but now you have to spend that and and
it's it's a it's a it's a spiral so what
once you once you have a year where you
don't spend thee it's hard to get out of
that over time okay thank you very
much one second so let's come back to uh
TANF ages on line item one for example
where it says so that families so
families so that children what what
what's the definition of child in that
what what's the age age range of a child
in that sentence it's up to age 18 uh
unless the child is still in high school
or equivalency to high school until
they're
19 represent torki thank you um I was
reading something recently and I'm
wondering how this fits if it fits into
tanif or if it fits in the child care
scholarship program um which is
assistance for children who have
children so a a mother a teen mother
let's say
um is there any special program or
benefit that assists them with automatic
Child Care scholarship so they can
continue their
education I don't think the criteria is
any different or extra in that
circumstance so they the the child that
needs the child care would still need to
meet the criteria for the scholarship
program regardless of the age of their
parent
or or the fact if they're living with a
parent the grandparent let's say sure so
when they're looking at uh income
eligibility for the program there are
circumstances when the grandparents
income may not be counted okay um but in
in all uh intents and purposes when the
three generations are in one household
it's not counted but otherwise it would
be okay thank you
[Music]
so a a homework assignment I I'd
appreciate it if um if you would um take
a look again at the Nebraska
program and and come back and tell me
sort of in the F three or four major
bullets what does it do because I think
that program does more than just giving
money to the Family Resource Centers and
say do more I I think there there's
actually a program with objectives in
there have you had a chance to look at
that particular program I have not I'm
sorry oh okay um so I I think I emailed
all that information about six seven
eight months ago so maybe hopefully
there's somebody in your department
who's taking a look at it I will
absolutely look at that all right
representative walner yes I want to know
are there any circumstances in New
Hampshire where a two parent family
could be eligible for tanif
go come up come up and sit at the end of
the table and and use one of those
microphones and we need you to introduce
yourself for the
record so my name is colie McKinley and
I work for um sorry is that better all
right so my name is colie kley and I
work for um Bureau of family assistance
under the policy development unit um and
the and I'm not sure did you ask sorry
representative w i just ask if there
were any circumstances in New Hampshire
where a two parent family could receive
tanii at this time there is it's um if
one of the parents is either
incapacitated or
disabled great thank you you're
welcome any other
questions all
right I'm I'm I'm I I shouldn't say it
this way but I'm I'm just a little
irritated because the last budget
briefing where we talked about tanif I
pointed out this number four and I I
said to please come forward in this
budget cycle with an explicit program so
we have a program that intentionally and
actively supports bullet 4
so I I I know you guys are really busy
but I I was hoping to to have a a
PowerPoint slide that says okay here's
what we're going to
do you did and I apologize for not
bringing that forward all right
represent walner I wondered if somebody
here who's had little history of New
Hampshire has there ever been a proposal
in the legislature around a two around
the two parent
program not to my
knowledge but my knowledge is probably
limited there is somebody in the
audience who think go go same thing just
take the chair and light up the mic and
introduce
yourself Chris ananello associate
commissioner I'm not sure if it was in
the legislature but I recall and Karen I
think um there's an issue with the work
participation rates because it's much
higher with a
twers with a two parent household than
we currently have now and we would have
difficulty um maintaining
that yes yeah I think the participation
rate goes up to 90% for two parent
family which yes which is why we stopped
doing the that particular program a few
years ago because we couldn't meet the
rate and we get penalized for not
meeting it
I thought we had had a program or had
had it proposed in the past okay thank
you but but I think that's why if we
look at something uh that we can um
develop those services that is not
directly the benefit we are providing
from the Department if we use Tana
funding to support services outside of
what we do internally that's where we
may be able to to do something
different thank you so so I'd like to
propose that you you take it away to
come up with another PowerPoint slide or
something that would specifically
address for and then attach that you can
come in and spend like eight minutes on
some other division 3 hearing that we
have I'd be happy to okay and then you
know M Mr Whitey and Mr Ripple will
figure out which which one would be the
most appropriate to tack you on but I I
I do I do want to take a second dip at
that
all right go ahead so slide 16
essentially gives a bit of a a highlevel
overview of the different areas that
we're looking for for uh tanif uh
spending so while we will put together a
more formalized plan for this I can tell
you that the um the the federal
government expects that states will
invest primarily in cash assistance uh
and work programs uh and education so
this includes barrier reduction uh to to
lifting families out of
poverty uh and also reduces incidents of
involvement with the child welfare
system so those are some of the key uh
focuses of the funding that the federal
government is
expecting
um we want to ensure that we're
identifying how to best measure outcomes
of the tanif funding activities uh and
what data to collect so in a plan I will
incorporate that um more
specifically um so these particular
items so between cash assistance and the
New Hampshire employment program um then
afterwards we're looking at the uh
Family Resource Center support including
the comprehensive Family Support
Services which is a lot of Home visiting
services and prevention prevention of
child welfare
intervention um and then Family Planning
looking at educational programs for
adults and
teenagers we are funding uh a small
amount for reunification of family
engagement for children who are in
foster care right now uh we provide
funds to Social Service uh uh transfer
to the Social Services Grant and then of
course looking at transferring Tana
funding for the child care and uh the
childcare Subs
rather on the 16 you have Family
Planning listed
M who who who who are some of the key
vendors currently providing these Family
Planning
services that is a good question I will
have to get that answer I don't know it
okay I I just have a quick follow-up
question to that what what's the nature
of the services
provided uh it's a lot of um so for
teenagers for example um prevention of
pregnancies um um abstinence programs so
really that that's the focus of those so
so to get to the implicit point this is
not paying for abortions
no was that your question
I think that's that's probably right no
it's education
only slide 17 I wanted to give you a
little bit of data um this comes from
our federal partners that collect data
from States uh this the the the the most
recent data that they publish is from
2023 but I would say it probably hasn't
changed so much in the last year um but
I think that this gives you a bit of an
idea of the effectiveness of the
services uh not necessarily
effectiveness of the program because
it's difficult to measure uh but also
the accountability of the services that
are being provided so if you look at
2023 14% of uh the uh uh recipients of
tanif gained
employment 9 and a half% uh found
themselves over income for the program
and that could have been from anything
from Child support payments started
coming in or other uneed income like
Social
Security there uh is an interesting
number here of the nearly
40% who closed their tanif program
because they were weed uh not in
compliance with any particular
requirement so if you're going to be
receiving TANF certainly you have to
cooperate with the child support
program um there are teen parent
requirements you have to develop a work
plan and work with the New Hampshire
employment program we've got some people
who don't show up for appointments or
didn't submit proper
verifications so but that's an
interesting number because I think that
it leads us to ask some of the questions
about well why uh did those things
happen uh are we explaining things well
enough to people uh where should we
focus our efforts in making any
particular improvements
do you you you probably at some point
Benchmark these against other similarly
sized and situated States just to see
how we're how these numbers in isolation
is are just data there's no way to
interpret this without a benchmark yeah
I like to look at States particularly in
the mid Midwest because they seem
comparable to New Hampshire more than
other states um so
and I would say that they're
comparable representative
priest thank you Mr chairman again I'm
back on page
16 um do you have actually numbers of of
uh families or individuals that you
provided assistance with for each of
these
programs and then my second question is
do you have the data for um on slide
17 um for
2024 so on the data on SL 17 for 2024 I
can get for you this was most readily
available directly from the um Federal
website uh but we have the data for 24 I
just need to have it pulled from the
system for you what about on page um 16
do you have like the number of people
you've served so I benefited from these
Services I do have um some numbers for
the comprehensive Family Support
Services I think that was right on the
slide
um yeah
1,158 families uh that were served by CF
the comprehensive Family Support uh I
will have to get numbers for the other
items such as the re be great thank you
so much short represent no vanum just a
very quick question I realize there are
a lot of variables in these on the page
17 you on that the on the right hand
side there but is that you know uh
patterns that look similar or the are
there any major areas where the patterns
have changed over the last five years um
I I don't think significantly enough I
think this is relatively consistent be
happy to provide you with I guess some
of that may show up in the 20 20 24
numbers that uh representative priest
asked for thank you
sure so should I be concerned that it
looks like only about
25% of tanif is being successful I mean
if you define success as gaining
employment or making the income or
resources to no longer qualify if you
define that as success we we only got
about a quarter of the people
participating in TANF graduating with
honors what what
what how how do how how do we think what
how do you think about that
number so I think that we need to do um
more as far as how we determine the
outcome metrics for uh things like the
work program that TANF is funding so how
do we know the program is effective are
people staying in their employment um
and for how long so they're actually new
metrics being put into place for the
system right now uh that are not
complete uh But it includes measuring
people's um uh the outcome of of the
employment rate for example two quarters
after they exit the tan of program and
then again four quarters after they exit
the tan of program uh so and then
looking at comparable um uh data of
their earnings uh so when they exited
the program and then after a period of
time like the second quarter or six
months after that what is their income
looking at that time so this is
collaboration also with the New
Hampshire employment security uh to be
able to uh receive that particular data
we also want to look at the uh
achievements people have been able to
make after tanif uh with respect to
their education so how many people are
attaining a high school diploma or an
equivalency for example after they've
exited the program within the first
year do you consider trade schools also
and and not just uh high school and and
colleges or going and attend getting a
trade that that counts right uh that is
actually not part of the metric today um
or that's being planned right now it's
basically based on High School uh uh
graduation or equivalency of high
school okay you're so you're not looking
at like going on and getting an
Associates or The Bachelors
or no okay all
right did you did you tell me what you
think about that 25% you think we can do
a lot better than that do we think
that's a that's probably it's natural
state we should learn to be satisfied
with that so
I think it's helpful to know and and and
understand that we're well first we've
we've been Limited in what we've been
able to measure as far as looking at
outcomes and success but one of the
primary metrics for the tan of program
and the Employment Program is the work
participation rate so how many
individuals are actually participating
in the work program which includes
they're either working or they are
participating in activities to find and
gain employ employment or they're going
to school so right now we have a higher
participation rate than we have had in
years it's over 69% at the moment um we
have to have a minimum of 50% per the
federal programs requirements uh but we
at the moment have just over
69% participation rate so so that sounds
like the good news I'm not seeing that
on your slide it's in the Bureau of
Employment support sorry it's in a
future slide oh okay all right preview
of Coming Attractions thank
you representative Daniels thank
you I hear you talk about the the
employment and going back and checking
to make sure that they're still employed
x amount of time later which is things
that Employment Security can do but I
haven't heard you talk about the
39.4% that don't fulfill the requirement
and you find trying to find out why
they're not doing that right so and we
don't track people after they close in a
program we simply just don't track
people after we're not providing them
with a service anymore that's what makes
it so difficult to determine how
effective this program is um I think we
end up having to uh either do our best
to try to understand based on feedback
we get from clients based on uh uh
forums or uh any kind of a a study that
we can conduct with various populations
about why uh they made decisions that
they did in order for us to improve
programs those are very limited it's
limited feedback uh because it's tough
to to get people to engage when they're
no longer being served by the
department
proceed so I will go to slide 18 which
essentially introduces a little bit of
work requirements um uh for the family
assistance program under this uh this
area so this has to do with the snap
program supplemental nutrition uh
nutrition assistance program so there is
a requirement for recipients of snap um
a particular population of them uh that
we refer to uh this is a federal term as
able-bodied adult without
dependence so these are people who are
at least 18 between 18 and 55 who are
fit to
work do not have a minor child in their
household uh and they have to meet
certain uh requirements work
requirements in order to continue
receiving the SNAP
benefit so the requirement includes 80
hours at least a month of either work or
being actively participating in a work
program or educational program currently
there is 281 individuals doing
that and that is
um the number of people who are
determined to be able-bodied adults
without dependence um comes from a uh
the population of the snap uh recipients
snap recipients it's over 70,000 people
right now but we carve out just those
individuals for these work requirements
who fit this definition and this
criteria 18 to 55 uh who don't have a
minor child in their household so it's a
much smaller segment of the snap
population where does that age bracket
come from the federal
government and in this case it's the US
Department of Agriculture and the food
and nutrition service uh branch of that
uh
Department there is a time limit that we
track where folks are allowed up to 3
months of the benefit if they're not yet
working or participating in a work
program or they're exempt from
participating for some reason so right
now there is 560 indiv uals who are not
yet participating in a program and will
need to or they will lose their benefit
after 3
months representative priest for a
question thank you madam uh Vice
chairman um back to your page on
18 um this slide mainly pertains to
those who are between 18 and
55 but um who are Able Body adults
without any children do you have any
programs for this same statistic but
with children with
dependence yes so we have an employment
and training program specifically for
SNAP recipients okay uh that is
voluntary for SNAP recipients and that's
a fairly new program that we are trying
to build and I going to talk about that
a little bit and how new is it um and do
you have any numbers for that I I I do
uh and I will make them available to
them yes okay thank you so much but it's
probably I don't know maybe three or
four years old maybe it's very
new okay but you can provide us with the
numbers okay thank you yes
representative Neno for a question thank
you uh Madam co-chair um really quick
question uh some level what kind of
exemptions that uh under the category of
limited exemptions and does that mean
the same kind of a thing a three-month
limitation or or how does that uh fit
into this bear with me I will find you
that
answer so the total number of
individuals who who fell into this uh
this this requirement uh is
11,737 people um so some of the
exemptions include
pregnancy uh if you're in a substance
misuse
program if you are receiving uh Social
Security or veterans
benefits if you're an eligible student
over
18 If you're receiving an employment
benefits if you're disabled or caring
for a disabled adult those
are a a a book of
them really quick followup eligible
student over 18 which means somebody is
attending part-time at part-time or
full-time yes further education programs
M okay thank you
representative
PRI thank you Mr chairman um back to
your response to the previous
representative could you make that
available to us so we just have that
information y thank you very much
sure all right I apologize for having to
step away i' I've got loads of
contractors in my new house and if you
miss one of those calls you could be
messed up for a long time so so thank
you so you're on you're on about to go
on to 19 I have completed 19 but if you
have questions of course no there's that
70% figure on the tan of participation
rate what what what tell tell me what
that means outcomes and results you got
a a 70% tan of participation
rate which slide are you referring to
I'm looking at 19 I'm not sure how to
what it's it's like there's a word or
two missing from that
bullet oh I seem to the bottom right
hand corner of page 19 outcomes and
results yes so
um the yeah near 70% participation rate
that is the number the percentage of
recipients of TANF who are participating
in the New Hampshire employment program
um got it and and that's you think
that's the right number or do we want
that to be 85% or
something uh so that's the the that
number is the highest it's been for many
many years but of course we want to
continue uh to increase that all right
thank you you're welcome uh
representative
priest thank you Mr chairman uh along
with that question do you have numbers
of the previous years that we can see
the um increase rates on these items of
outcomes and results sure and again
congratulations and getting an 8.2
increase that's
great
certainly so this really is where we uh
get into a little bit more of the Bureau
of Employment supports and what it does
uh which is really uh working with
individuals who are re recipients of
tanif and snap uh who are required to
participate in work activities so that
they can
become
self-sufficient uh so we have both the
New Hampshire employment program and the
snap employment and training program
both are in order to uh accomplish the
same thing uh gain work experience gain
work uh employment uh and obtain
self-sufficiency so this program works
uh directly with employers uh and
educational training organizations uh
the workforce Innovation Opportunity Act
uh group under their state plan New
Hampshire Employment Security Department
of Business and economic Affairs and all
to address certain labor market
needs so using tanif funding New
Hampshire is well invested in employment
supports for tanif recipients so the
department administers this program for
its for low and income uh low-income
families who have children and the goal
is to basically end their dependency on
public assistance and promote job
preparation and employment so the career
counselors as these staff are called uh
are highly trained they provide services
on Workforce Development education case
management and reducing barriers to
employment uh and prepare people for
industry specific
representative yes thank you thank you
you
uh Mr chairman quick question do you
have you have any issues and any people
that look at the question of abuse in
the in the EBT and the snap
programs or do we have questions Fraud
and Abuse so I think we're we're
constantly keeping our eyes open for
that and sometimes we receive reports
from Anonymous sources or from uh people
that might know something uh that report
things to us that are then referred to
our special investigations unit is that
significant as a follow-up question you
see that as a significant issue or or
not no
um I have some information about that
bear with me and while you're looking at
that who who is the special
investigative division so that falls
under the division of program quality
Integrity uh with
mer to lose yes so essentially when
there is a misuse of tanif funds uh the
federal government can assess penalties
uh with the individuals or institutions
that might uh have been at fault for any
kind of fraud so uh what we know of in
other states uh and this data is is a
few years old uh however it it it may be
still relevant in 2020 there were
charges brought against six State
officials for misappropriating T of
funding New Hampshire is not one of
those
States uh in Mississippi there were
eight criminal defendants and 47 civil
dependents that the Department of Human
Services is suing in an attempt to
recoup $77 million and stolen and
misspent federal funds so we have
preventative measures and monitoring
activities under state law uh and rules
for penalties of anyone who is misusing
um uh tan of funding and we have an
admin an electronic benefit transfer
administrator who is monitoring that
activity uh based on the transactions
that they are looking at uh we have
restricted
locations uh for uh example certain
business types that are blocked uh that
may be close to uh ATMs to establishment
such as liquor stores Casino or gambling
establishments or any retail
establishments that provide adult
oriented entertainment smoke shops
tattoo parlors marijuana
dispensaries uh so I can say that
between December 1st of 2018 through
September 30th of
2023 and I can get you some updated
numbers but not a single transaction has
been attempted at a restricted location
in New Hampshire
ju just a quick follow and this purely
observational anecdotical I see you know
sometimes the places that I frequent
personal AC places that go in and out of
the you know you'll see a sign that you
know they were accepting EBT and they're
no longer accepting EBT and I you know
kind of curious as to why um uh
businesses or places where at one point
are accepting and at another time not
accepting there issues with the with the
how they're reimbursed or the funding or
anything that would would cause that
kind of a pattern no I I think that the
um federal government that includes the
US Department of Agriculture for snap
and the administration for children and
families for tanv really look at a
variety of ways they can promote the
utilization of SNAP benefits uh in
particular or tanif benefits so I think
that that's essentially uh
arrangements for promotional public U
materials uh that that promote those
programs from those establishments so
grocery stores for example we'll make a
note of that um I I see them in various
places as well but that's not
administered by the
department okay thank you
sure thank you maybe you can help me
reconcile some of the numbers you have
on page 19 you you you indicate that
close to 70% of the tanif participation
rates in employment programs but yet on
page 17 only 14% have gained
employment so I'm does that that mean
that we we have 56% of them that don't
gain employment so it it's fluid so you
may have um individuals who have gained
employment uh from numbers that were
were um uh put together from 2023
information this 70% of tan of
participation rate is as of
2024 um so the participation
rate doesn't necessarily mean they have
found
employment they could be participating
in the Employment Program and doing what
they're supposed to do but maybe they
haven't found work yet and I and I
understand that and but even one year
apart and the fact that 70% are in
training but the previous year only four
14% gained employment it it seems like
maybe something isn't working with the
training
programs and that goes back to wanting
to make sure that we're collecting the
right data so that we can report out on
that and it's really difficult to do we
just initiated a uh um a post tanif
program that's very new uh it it's being
done in a few other states as well but
it's a very New Concept to try to work
with people after they've closed tanif
in order to track them and how well that
they're doing whether they've gained
employment or they're still searching
that is a voluntary program uh that we
would track people who volunteer for
that for a year after their tanif
benefit closes so hoping we could
perhaps gain some better understanding
as to what the effectiveness is here
okay thank
you so on
um let's see where should I go next uh I
don't think we looked at the um
y go ahead representative thank you Mr
chair I I wasn't going to ask this but I
am you then I second thought I'm going
to ask it are there
any any of the uh any disincentives
built into the uh eligibility
requirements that would for example
would discourage somebody from looking
for full-time work and I'm looking at
the 80 hours a month if you go over a
certain threshold uh are there any um
situations where you know not going to
work would would reduce the amount of
total uh income you have and and if
there are what you know what can you do
to eliminate disincentives right so
couple of things so for that uh
able-bodied program for
example uh somebody would be uh able to
receive up to three months and it
doesn't have to be consecutive months up
to three
months that if they're not participating
in a work program or working they would
lose their benefit it would
close for the tanif program if they're
not meeting certain requirements so
somebody is supposed to uh participate
in the work program and they're not then
they would face sanctions that
ultimately starts with a reduction in
their Grant and could lead to uh the uh
benefit
closing thank you welcome all right so
so now you're on 19 beginning Bureau of
Employment
supports uh yes uh unless you want to go
through the accounting units for the
Bureau of family assistance director's
office so so this is what I'm thinking
since we're going to have to come back
anyways this is as good a stopping point
as anyway to keep the Integrity of your
presentation together so we can complete
a section so so so I think uh we should
take um a recess to to go get some food
uh how much time do you think uh we need
representative tersi 45 minutes come
back at
12:45 that sounds okay all right do do
you does a department have any issues
with coming back at 12:45 no all right
um all right so with that uh we're in
recess until
12:45
e
e e
a one minute warning one minute
warning all right it's it's uh 12:45 I'm
going to bring division 3 out of recess
we'll pick up where we left
off page 19 of uh the Department's slide
deck um and uh welcome back hope
everyone had a good
lunch thank you uh so I wanted to just
um uh for a point of clarification
because I think it would be really
helpful on um one of the tanif slides
specifically
um slide
17 the data that's there with respect to
percent percentages of various
circumstances that's actually
representative of cases that have closed
for those reasons in that year and I
didn't write that I didn't so I wanted
to make sure that that was clear and it
may uh alleviate some
confusion I I I thought it was clear
enough but appreciate the clarification
I it it totals to about 100% so I I
figured it was meant to be inclusive so
right yep those are reasons for cases
closing their
tanif uh so uh I think we could move to
slide
20 which takes us back to the um
accounting units for the direct starting
with the director's
office if there are any questions on
that
just excuse me thank you just one quick
comment that's where we said I think
previous earlier this this in this
morning session that there were what 741
positions in there and 47 417 of those
were unfunded is that that I catch that
right um
good afternoon Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer with the Department of
Health and Human Services So within the
division of economic stability and the
governor's State fiscal year 26
recommended budget there's
587 and and I believe uh there's
approximately 74 73 that are unfunded
within this
division okay so I'm I'm that where is
that in the in the book
it's included in those uh so if if you
look at page
885 of the governor's uh recommended
budget ah okay at the end um you'll see
the totals for the division uh both in
terms of dollars as well as the
classified and unclassified full-time
authorized
positions okay thanks I was just on our
own page thank you
it's very quick followup those are all
funded in that in those numbers no so so
there there and I've been corrected uh
there's 73 unfunded positions that are
included in that total thank you and and
those dollars have been removed from the
from the class 10 and class 60 uh lines
so so the the the reduction in in
funding is is reflected in the totals
you see in the bottom
and I'm sure there's a reason for this
but I'm just looking at um on page 866
of the of the budget book under um
grants for public assistant and relief
074 there's 1.1 million
there um and this is under the
director's office so I'm just curious
about the placement of that size account
doing grants in a director's office
shouldn't that be under more of an
operational
Bureau that specifically funds uh a
contract for SNAP education which is
100% federal
funds okay so so there's not a different
Bureau for SNAP education this is the
most logical place to put that correct
okay
I I I I do have a question about
education in general and maybe maybe you
could uh bring me back to this uh Mr
White because you you picked up on some
of this last budget cycle we we had um a
group in public health that did um
public Communications did you know sort
of Outreach
messaging then we had a special source
of money that came in and we decided
that we were going to set up I think
sort of I think it was a um the brain
disorder a separate PR program and they
ran in parallel one of the things I said
was I'd like to see only one Department
in the dep in the Department of Health
and Human Services that manages sort of
public facing Education and
Training and I and I know that not in
here but um talking about education here
just triggered that thought sure are you
referring to the public awareness
campaign on brain health Alzheimer's
disease and related dementias yeah yeah
that was a special project and it was
supposed to be a onetime project because
there was no marketing collaterals and
they just needed to be
some what what what did we do with that
did they we roll that up into something
else for the coming budget or did we
ongo it no so that was a onetime
appropri of
$500,000 um I believe it was it was made
out of the um the Surplus uh funds from
State fisc year 23 so that has not been
budgeted going forward perfect thank you
sorry Miss Hebert I I rained on your
parade no representa
walner thank you I'm just wanted to pick
up on something that um Mr White just uh
sort of alluded to
um the 73 unfunded positions and I
should have asked this in more not just
here but throughout when we've been
going through the
budget how do we how do we decide which
are unfunded and what is that going to
mean for um a division like this when
their uh Workforce is that reduced sure
so
um there's there's two pieces of statute
that are really critical for the
Department to be successful um one is
currently in RSA and and that's the
authority that allows us to fill
unfunded positions the second piece is
currently in hb2 the final hb2 should
should be out here soon um that allows
us to move money out of between
Personnel lines essentially and um the
department has a central team that we
utilized during the last hiring fre
where
basically we have a centralized process
where requests come in and we look
globally at the Department's needs so
that we look at what are the overall
operating needs um and there it's it's
certainly a bit of a balance as far as
posting the right positions and looking
at what are the needs in the community
what are the needs what are the support
needs what are the Direct Care needs
that you know certainly takes precedence
and importance there um so there's
certainly no good answer but we do do
already have a process in place to try
to address this as dynamically and
nimbly as as we
can so
um in a division like this
one
where I I'm not sure what these 73
unfunded positions are but um I would
think that some of them might be
eligibility
workers and I know that just from my own
known experience in working with
families they often talk about you know
how long it takes for them to um apply
get on Ser get a service and I'm
wondering what does what happens to the
uh workload and what happens to the the
lag of time for for these
families so I have
um yeah
as you address that would you also talk
about new heights I think that's the
eligibility system and any improvements
to productivity we've gotten there yes I
have that incorporated into my
presentation so I'm going to talk a
little bit about that but I will say
that um it's
concerning as to what the impact of not
being able to hire in these positions is
going to have on clients uh and their
ability to serve them
um it's pretty significant um training
for this the the majority of staff are
new they're considered to be trainees in
field eligibility uh it's like 60 some
odd percent of them takes 9 to 12 months
to go through training um and there are
people who leave because they realize
this is not something that I can do um
so the more people we have a lot of term
we have a lot of turnover uh in this
particular area of the division uh so we
have a number of different strategies
and things that we're trying to
accomplish that I'm going to talk about
um but there is still nonetheless uh
some significant concerns and challenges
going forward to meet the demand and
meet the needs of people if we can't
fill these positions
thank you so yeah I think that uh the
numbers I have are about 69 positions
that are in uh field uh the field uh
side of the house of BFA right now so so
if I take what Mr White said and what
you just said is that um the vacant
positions that you have get thought
about in this more centralized group as
the total group takes looks at the
priorities overall in the department and
that there is at least been some kind of
an active decision for these
vacancies although you it's probably
still the case that you would want
more yes uh definitely uh so it's pretty
much my responsibility to ensure that
those who are making the decisions about
priorities understand what the impacts
are if we were not able to fill certain
positions
and and what one of the hopes from two
two budget Cycles ago now I'm on my
third is that when we talked about New
Heights and it sounds like you're about
to talk about New Heights anyways but um
that as we spent actually a a huge ramp
up in it you know three budgets ago from
being nearly zeroed out um that the Hope
was by investing in in systems like new
heights that we would uh gain a
tremendous productivity enhancement
because we'll have a tool in place so
that new heights is now you know five
years old or so or or at least the
biggest revisions could could could you
talk about how that system has uh
affected the productivity of your
eligibility
[Music]
team there have been numerous
enhancements made to new heights I would
like to say probably a majority of them
based on changes or new requirements of
our federal Partners or under state law
um that the funding limits what we are
then able to do just to make things
perhaps more efficient for staff that
often is not at the top of the list um
so we're looking at changing I'm going
to talk about business models and the
things that we're doing in planning for
both the it system and and um business
models for the Bureau of family
assistance that should uh
support greater efficiencies for staff
um uh but yes there's certainly always
more we need to improve upon because our
environment is changing constantly and
we need to be leveraging the systems
that we have to keep up with that and it
takes a long time to be able to
implement any kind of
develop design and develop first but
then Implement changes that are going to
be needed so we're we're often I think a
little behind in keeping up with demand
of the changes that are actually needed
um because it does take a long time to
be able to implement
[Music]
those so moving on with the accounting
unit under the Bureau of family
assistance I'm looking at slide 21 uh
there is the accounting unit for
tanif so the rest of the accounting
units in this particular Bureau uh Are
all uh the various state and federal
assistance
programs
um and the funding needed to provide
those
benefits to each of those populations
thank you Mr chairman on that page 868
on line
074 grants for public assistance and
relief there's a significant
increase um for 2026 and
2027 can you explain what's what was
happening with that
uh for I'm sorry is there a particular
class line you're focusing on yeah
074 okay
yep employment support I'm sorry
flipping through pages
here so this essentially is uh Workforce
Development contracts um we have two
vendors that provide services
specifically for um uh more of the
longer term more intense uh activities
for people who are in the Employment
Program um so what we've added into
these contracts is the ability to
implement the post tanif support
programs that includes the ability to
track those
individuals okay and and that class line
is 100% federal funds okay what about
may I continue on the next line uh
contracts for program
Services I'm sorry yes you have zero in
existing years but then you're up 1.5
million in each year yep so this is um
uh this
is an a enhancement or E expansion
rather of the snap employment and
training program to essentially offer
Support Services through uh a new vendor
uh that we would be uh having do case
management of their uh
employment um uh activities job search
uh resume Development Career building uh
or what tuition or what um education
they may need credentialing that they
may need
uh so that's that's the increase there
okay thank
you the remaining accounting units under
the Bureau of family assistance so we
have uh each of those programs um some
of them are under a million dollars
so it's not identified in the briefing
book
um if there are any questions about
those def definition of older children
for a state separate State Tana program
uh 19 to 20 19 to 26 I believe these are
children coming out of uh foster
care okay that's really old
all
right couple years later they'll be on
Social
[Music]
Security they may now
be
um any further questions on those
accounting units I'll pause for a bit on
page
22 you'll probably get some questions on
Refugee grants tell you know tell us
tell tell us how much we're this is all
100% Federal do and we don't see any
indication that um money to support the
refugees that we've already been
assigned are going to be
pulled I have no indication of that have
you heard anything Mr
White nothing official I mean similar to
the conversation we had earlier I think
there's still a lot of unknowns at this
point all right
surprised the snap incentive program is
under a million dollars what does that
do snap incentive program uh I think
it's
$100,000 um essentially
to
fund what's known as a double up food
bucks program
essentially it's to promote the purchase
of healthy foods vegetables fruits so
that it incentivizes people to make
those purchases because it'll give you
double the value double the uh your
money's worth in those purchases up to
$20 a day
represent
priest thank you Mr chairman again as i'
have discussed before would it be
possible to to get figures of how many
people you provide
services with all the bureau family
assistance and if you have any previous
years we would like to see that too if
that's possible how many years would you
like well how many year let's say five
years okay prior are are we basically
asking you to replicate that what's in
these um these uh budget briefing books
isn't a lot of this data the the details
previous years are there I I don't know
I'm asking I'm asking a question because
we haven't consulted the budget briefing
book today and I'm just curious if the
questions we're asking on the PowerPoint
have been anticipated and put into the
budget briefing book so so that that's a
question yeah so I'll the history is not
included in the briefing book so I think
I can simply provide uh some a table of
the different programs and numbers over
a fiveyear period if that would be
helpful that would be great thank you
sure anything else on those accounting
units
okay the
um slide 23 is specific to employment
supports it is Incorporated in the
Bureau of family assistance budget but
it is its own Bureau and its own
accounting unit uh specifically for that
particular
program what what you've mentioned the
that you're developing new outcome
measures a couple of times already and
then it's in in this bullet again uh
what what are you doing how are you
doing that what what's your process so
essentially the metrics for example for
tanif um changes of the the requirements
for that have been handed down from
Federal Regulations so it's essentially
uh just working them into the system so
that new heights can track that
information and then issue Federal
reports for it as
required representative
PRI thank you Mr chairman on page 86
7 line 085 inter agency transfers out of
f um can you just give us more
explanation about what's happening
there
sure okay so the 2024 was
31,000 it is adjusted this year for 153
and then it jumps up to
705 I think I may be on the wrong page
probably
867 that's why I didn't see
it so this okay I see
it just looking at the split big J yep
so this is um transfers uh for funding
uh that supports uh exchanges of
information with Employment Security and
the State Workforce Innovation board uh
it also serves as the uh passed through
for federal funding for the community
college system that promotes uh the
employment and training services for
SNAP
recipients okay thank you you're
welcome just a quick question that's UNH
that we're talking about there uh it's
the community college system oh
community col thank
you
okay so I would then uh introduce us to
the oh sorry yes I'm sorry um back on
page 867 contracts for operational
Services I imagine um Zero from the last
year and the justed year this year but
it jumps up to
$3.8 million uh for the next two years
can you just give us some reading on
that
please so so uh if if you look at class
uh 74 you'll see that that was zeroed
out um oh I see okay yeah those funds
were moved into into 10 um into
103 and and again part of that's done
for tracking purposes where when we have
100% federally funded contractor
agreement we track it in 74 and and
you'll see those movements throughout
throughout the years pretty commonly
okay thank
you then I would invite you to join me
in reviewing the other half of the
Bureau of family assistance specifically
our field operations
and starting on p uh slide
24 so the field operation side of the
house this is where uh this is where the
eligibility determinations are made uh
by these particular staff um so the the
the bureau here assists of course
individuals and families to access
approximately 50 different medical and
economic Assistance programs so that's
the service that they're providing
basically enabling people to access
those Assistance programs they are uh
responsible to determine Financial
eligibility for all of the programs
including long-term care applications so
we have folks who apply for Medicaid but
then also who apply through this uh
long-term care unit specifically for um
long-term care so Nursing Facility or
the Medicaid waiver for um uh choices
for Independence known as
CFI we provide services to the public
through 11 different district offices
plus three uh additional units that do
not have people come meet with them in
person but they do provide Direct
Services over the phone for folks that
includes long-term care uh a number of
uh staff who work on eligibility cases
uh in a State office location and our
disability determination
unit so a question there you um on the
long-term care
collaboration uh are are these the these
are the
people who take a look at a client's
needs and assess their clinical care
needs and by assessing their clinical
care needs they go into the long-term
care setting with some sort of Acuity
rating of some kind and and and the
amount of money that gets reimbursed is
dependent upon that Acuity rating is is
that what these folks do no I I would
say that's likely more through our
Managed Care organizations that
determine level and types of care this
is essentially to be determined eligible
financially and eligible medically for
long-term care services what the
services are moves to a different area
under Medicaid so so I don't I don't
think that our mcos do long-term care
they they don't they don't get into the
U the evaluation of the care but but the
bottom line is you're not doing
evaluation of the level of care needed
for these folks you're doing simply the
financial assessment correct which is
probably why I didn't answer that
correctly no no no that's fine the
because I'm just coming up to speed on
how we do uh the the care assessments
and there's been some discussion about
moving that to uh to the
counties that would not affect your
department other than you would still
probably be involved in the financial
assessment we're engaging with uh at
least one particular County to look at a
Pilot so that the county could assist in
determining eligibility Financial
for long-term care
services um the the hope is that it
would perhaps uh build capacity for the
ability to process those uh effectively
and And Timely I I think Miss Santella
wants to make me smarter what what what
are you going to say sure um you will
hear about um the medical eligibility
that's done under the division of
long-term supports and services when
Melissa hard's here next week okay and
and so miss Hebert's group and that
group collaborates to create essentially
a client profile of Financial and
medical needs correct is that is that
sort of profile building is that done in
New Heights or how is how is that sort
of integrated view of the client where
where's that house New Heights that's in
New Heights yes Adam said so and and in
what Adam said so oh okay so he's right
I'm sure and and then is New Heights A
system that our mcos also
touch not for that eligibility no do our
um counties interact with new
heights there's different levels of
access and Adam is going to talk about
that because he is New Heights and is
New Heights a software only server or
Services of
software uh Adam lcan I'm the project
manager for New Heights uh so so I think
the first question was the counties we
have as Karen said the the pilot for
Mart County to be able to have access to
and and sure and assist uh uh on the
financial side um I don't believe that
has kicked off just yet no uh and for
was second question software as a
service well I wanted to know if the
mcos use New Heights and and Miss
Santella just said no not for long-term
care no they they do they they have
access to new I'm sorry to interrup no
no no so you're about to answer the rest
so the mcos do have access to uh New
Heights very minimal uh uh information
we share with them it's really just that
uh they're able to go in and look at
individuals that are eligible with them
yeah and they can see their information
their Medicaid information in in Heights
they're not they don't have any update
access to the system and and so is that
application offered as software as a
service is that a a cloud-based uh no
everything is on Prem we we own it the
state uh it's it's um uh at Hazen drive
and you install fat clients thin clients
uh it's uh web web clients it's all kind
of Thin Client is the old term and I'm
old so okay that that that helps because
there's a there's another discussion
happening in background on what we
should do with long-term service support
whether we should be talking about
migrating that to the mcos and what that
would do and so I just want to know how
this financial eligibility would have to
go along with that so thank thank you
for the Side Bar no
problem so this is an area of the
division so the Bureau of family
assistance uh in field operations that
is experiencing many challenges to
providing quality services to people
including meeting time frames and
reaching high performance um so I would
draw your attention to the outcomes that
really is all about the volume of work
that these folks are doing and at a 23%
vacancy rate among these
staff so we're challenged to conduct
these activities but as monthly these uh
folks are processing over 8,000
on average new
applications they are making over 13,000
redeterminations or renewals of
Eligibility uh for people
monthly we receive about 29,000 phone
calls uh uh monthly uh inbound calls uh
that's not even the total amount it's
only the amount we record from our tier
one call
center staff are processing over 91,000
documents a
month and making over 26,000 updates to
cases every month so the the volume is
extraordinary and challenged by the fact
that we have such a high vacancy rate in
this particular uh area so while we're
trying to provide services to about
200,000
people so so this is all great good data
I but but I like context and so one one
point of context is that's a tremendous
amount of work the way you you presented
it and emphasized it but but do you have
uh Manpower benchmarks to say you know a
person should only do 500 new applicants
a year or or each person should only do
a th do you have do you have sort of a
Manpower metric to be able to apply
consistent ly to the workload we're
dealing with we're trying to look uh
through a particular uh internal
committee at uh case loads and workloads
right now um so it it's been very
difficult to try to identify what are
those
benchmarks right so the answer is no I
don't have that but right now you can
calculate because you have actual work
and you have actual numbers of people
you can calculate the
current workload benchmarks because it
just is the numbers that you're dealing
with from there it would just
secondarily be what should the Benchmark
be if it should be below what you're
currently experiencing so sure and and I
think it changes though perhaps every
day because we have people that leave we
have people that are new trainees that
are not able to take on the full
workload that a seasoned uh eligibility
worker can take on uh they start off
slow they start off small and then build
from there once they reach certain
competencies yeah so it's difficult to
measure this um I get it thanks sure uh
representative priest did you have a
question yes I did and thank you for
acknowledging um and thank you for
taking my question again back on the
outcomes and results monthly was this a
particular month
or was this an average of all of the
months in 24 it's an average over the
last year
okay thank you
sure thank you so you uh spoke earlier
about it taking I think it was up to
nine months to train a person to for one
of these
positions are they required to
understand the eligib ility for each of
these programs both the state
eligibility and the federal
eligibilities it's eligibility yes for
all programs but it's also policy it's
procedures which are very detailed
there's a lot of well if it's this facts
set of facts then you do this if it's
that set of facts then you do that so
it's very um tedious it's a lot to learn
and understand and remember so we have a
a training unit to try to keep up with
the need which has been challenging as
well to do that um so that's where I
think some of the system changes and
plans that we're making may come into
place to assist with that so when you
hire a new person do
they go for training or do they start do
they actually is it sort of on the job
training so there's some preliminary
information but uh until they are uh
able to hit a a certain competency um
they're not allowed to uh be on their
own so to speak okay thank you
sure do does do your processes support
sort of a a
competency developed or
regulated um um uh
workflow capability like like if you got
a 100 cases you got 15 of them that are
really hard and 20 of them that are kind
of easy does your does your it does your
workflow manager basically allow the
development of of a of a workflow so
that you can have the appropriately um
ready competency dealing with that work
so the workload management is is they
they utilize a daily dashboard in a
sense it basically directs them on the
different tasks and things that they
need to accomplish next uh for any given
number of cases for any number of cases
not per client but correct okay and then
that that their clients the set of their
clients is based on like a degree of
difficulty is is your workflow manager
that good so or does everyone get the
same basic cut of of uh difficulty
I'll have to have my expert in that
answer this is where the productivity
really comes in you know is the extent
to which the workflow management of
these it systems are adaptable so that
you can you can hit the work that
they're able to do and then elevated it
as they get better so so what can you
tell us about this um I'm Carrie schroer
I'm the bureau chief for BFA field Ops
um so our trainees uh learn programs at
a time so they case load reflects that
so for example if somebody is brand new
coming in they'll learn all of the
policy and procedures for SNAP for
example once they um have a handle on
that then we add additional programs to
it in their case load they'll have a
mixed bag if you will so there will be
some that are you know straightforward
applications and some of them that
are more difficult I guess um and it's
really just to see what their competency
level is as they get added to and if
they don't um
continually progress then we go back and
then make sure that they're getting that
as they
go that's reassuring thank you yep so
representative tki and then
representative ala quick question when
we talk about eligibility I know that
children who are in households with TANF
or snap are um automatically eligible
for free and reduced lunch meals and I'm
just curious how that communication
happens with the Department of Education
and I believe that's just through an
interface with the Department of
Education okay okay yes I was right okay
it's an electronic interface with them
could the communication go the other way
too does it go the other way could the
communication go the other way
too
yeah thanks
yes thank you very much Mr chairman I I
think this is a a question that builds
on what uh representative Edwards was
asking and when I look at that list of
outcome and results uh and and listening
to what uh was said here I'm I'm
assuming that some of the staff are
handling um you know all of something in
all of these categories some maybe um uh
for example on the redeterminations
there's a a higher higher level of of
training and staff may be dedicated to
that is that is that a correct
characterization in terms of workflow so
and and then finally the case
updates sorry documents scanned and
indexed everybody must be doing that
right yes so uh we have a a unit that
specifically uh is responsible for the
documents that have been scanned
or uploaded from uh our self-service
portal and then index them so in other
words attach them um uh virtually
speaking to a particular case but then
the eligibility staff have to then take
each of those documents which they're
just images now of the documents and
then process them so depending on what
the document is Will dictate what needs
to be processed and how
um and I forget the first part of your
question
sorry um um I I think that answers the
the question so it's a it's a
combination of uh and attributable to
the level of training that's required in
order to to do some of these tasks some
of them are relatively mechanical tasks
yes uh some of them require some
judgmental uh determination according to
whatever the rules and the specific
program is so we have what what staff
that can that perform the eligibility
responsibilities are referred to as
generalists they essentially have to
know everything about everything uh
although the unit that manages long-term
care
applications that is uh quite a bit more
involved there's a significant amount of
manual work that has to be done with
reviewing long-term applications that
includes a 3 to 5e look back of
hundreds or if not thousands of pages of
documents uh to help determine whether
or not the individual is financially
eligible for long-term care there's a
lot of manual workarounds uh with our it
system right now for long-term care
which is in our plans to make
improvements but it it's tedious uh it
it requires a lot of very focused time
in reviewing each of those
documents thank you representative
priest thank you Mr chairman um back on
the outcomes and results um the monthly
average for
2024 um do you have figures of the
previous five years to see if if these
averages are going up or down or staying
the same uh for your workload so there
may be uh nuances or variables involved
in looking at p last years for example
um uh the inbound calls uh we've had uh
uh looking at different um metrics with
a couple of different vendors that have
been involved in our tier one call
center so there may be some Nuance
differences there um case updates
because cases change all the time
policies change all the time which means
procedures for staff change all the time
uh so they're could be some differences
there that are tough to uh to to compare
to past
years I could certainly give you um
something that might be relatively
comparable would be previous year that
would be great and and have you in the
past had the same kind of vacancy rate
of
23% or is that just being increased
because of the uh the market pressures
so we've had had a about a 20 to 23%
vacancy rate in this Bureau for several
years
okay thank
you okay this this isn't your issue but
um I've got a doctor's appointment uh
coming up I have about 25 more minutes
before I have to leave you guys can
continue but if we if uh if we
could try to do it in that time sure if
you want to go to slide 25 that
essentially gives you some
um history over the last year of each
month for the the tier one call center
this is an external uh contracted vendor
call center that basically answers calls
into a central location for the Bureau
of family assistance um this is a
prioritized need and it is a significant
prioritized need um I wanted to show you
that the um uh with a cost Center a tier
one call center we have two tiers
essentially tier 2 is made up of uh BFA
internal staff who are more experts to
handle complex questions or uh
information but the tier one answers a
lot of general
questions right now they have a 2.7
abandonment rate which is pretty good um
and a 17 minute average weit time which
seems like a long time but I will tell
you that without the call center we have
had about a 2 to three hour wait time I
don't like waiting for you know 10
seconds on the call never mind on that
so so you say this is a prioritized need
M Mr W were you present when this was
discussed with the governor's office
what sort of thought did they have on
this I I I I would have to go back and
and talk to them um relative to their
conclusion but I don't I don't believe
we had too extensive conversations
relative this how how much more money is
in the prioritized need request sure so
if you
turn to uh slide
36 of the
presentation you will see uh the
eligibility call center on the first
line there it's 1.8 million General
funds each year of the banum
yikes are these prioritized needs on the
back these five of them are they rank
ordered is this is this meant to be your
increment list of what you would do
first second third
um no I well I didn't rank them in that
sense okay we're going to need a ranking
if we're going to do anything with that
list so and then we're going to probably
need to know what sort of a minimum
essential opening bid might look like or
whether you know like for example
eligibility call center 1.8 in general
in the first year I mean all right so so
what what what what would 700,000 buy
you I I I I I need I need to know if
these are all or nothing or if there's
some sort of range in here sure I I I
think part of it would be dependent upon
what funds were available because we
would we would need to go out to um to
bid for them
yeah and if there was a fixed amount of
money then we would probably need to
disclose that in in the RFP or the
depending on the method that we'd want
to utilize to see what was a level of
service that we could get but Karen I
don't know if you want to speak to what
this would buy us at these
amounts so essentially this would give
us um uh a call center that would be
able to keep up with a required capacity
of inbound calls so that would include
not just the uh General phone number but
we would want them to be able to manage
inbound calls for long-term care and
other areas of the of the bureau so it
essentially would cover um training uh a
a
a uh a number of the uh customer service
Representatives um like perhaps about 35
to 40 Representatives answering the
calls and that they would also be able
to perform certain administrative
services for us where we may need them
such as Outreach activities uh that we
have had to do in the past
uh that just gives you I think a general
sense of of where we're going with that
um yeah
may may maybe we could set up a just a
office visit to talk about these
prioritized needs I I think I I just
need more Nuance in the in the detail
and uh I don't think we're ready to do
that today and I because I don't even
have my questions but but um I I think
some of these seem as I'm looking at 36
some of them appear as though they have
a business case behind them and I kind
of want understand the business case and
that may take more time than we have
here today so um I I I'm fairly
available I can come over sometime to
Brown to go through
this that's my offer definitely
representative priest do you have a
question or do you I do have a I do have
a question thank you too acknowledging
um um I'm on also on page uh 36 and and
in some of the lines like the
eligibility call center it just doesn't
add up so could someone go back and take
a look at that and also um in the same
vein as uh chairman Edwards I would like
to know if you have
any um cost efficiencies of these
priorities if for for instance if we
were able to fund some of these would
there be cost savings down the road and
how much would they be for the
Department that that's exactly what I
meant when I said these feel like they
have business cases that could be put
behind we need to yeah I I I would like
to see um the cost efficiencies um given
the fact that
there's so much demand for so little
money that we have to work with so that
would be great and also if you can just
take a look at the total on on some of
those lines uh I would appreciate it too
thank you yeah the the the totals are
are incorrect for the eligibility call
center um I I think one thing to
consider is sometimes when we put
together prioritized needs we're not
only thinking about cost efficiencies
we're also thinking about cost aversion
so so the snap error reduction rate that
that's an example of where if we were to
be able to improve our systems we would
lower the likelihood of of future
potential Federal
penalties so that's a business case that
is a business case right you know um
kind of a riskmanagement approach
representative seaworth thank you Mr
chairman hopefully this is
simple um when I look at for example the
eligibility call center there's a
general Federal split is that Federal
money we're currently ineligible for
that if we spent the 1.8 million we
would then able to
get uh so it it's essentially uh a
federal match to the general funds um
based on the percentages of the
program am I saying that right
okay and I guess just to make sure I'm
not misunderstanding it's
not it's Federal money in addition to
everything else that's already in the
budget not taking from some other areas
correct
correct so so represented tki you just
heard me invite myself to like an office
call to go into some more detail on
these business cases if if um your party
wants to send somebody with me so we
could just brainstorm it
together pardon me on the prioritized
needs on page 36 yes yes ma'am yeah I'd
like someone involv with that yeah no
I'll I'll uh I'll I'll keep you in the
loop as we develop a a potential
schedule because I I think I think that
you know three or four of us uh not from
the committee but someone from your
party my party and then the department
we could have a a a good quick
conversation all right what what what
can you do in 10
minutes I these next two slides 26 and
27 fascinate me well then let's go there
so these two slides are essentially
about New Heights uh the uh integrated
eligibility and enrollment system which
is no longer about just eligibility
Heights is actually an acronym uh which
stands for helping Empower individuals
get help
transitioning uh to
self-sufficiency uh so this uh the the
uh New Heights team essentially uh I
like to refer to as the central nervous
system of uh of the division uh which is
now really expanding into other
divisions as well including Medicaid and
long-term supports and services so we
want to continue uh adopting and
leveraging technology that is available
to us uh to just continuous Improvement
continuously creating more efficiencies
so that access is easier and that staff
have an easier time processing uh so
as you can see on the uh boxes to the
right this is my right um the number of
households that are in open cases right
now uh is over
133,000 there are a number of folks that
are that have given us permission to use
text and email for communicating with
them which certainly creates
efficiencies there are
133,000 active New Hampshire easy
accounts New Hampshire easy is the
web-based self-service portal that is
connected with the in uh the eligibility
system uh easy is an acronym it stands
for the electronic application system
and that's essentially what it is people
can apply online through it they can
create an account they can upload
documents to it they can communicate
with us through it um they can see the
status of their application and benefits
uh and a lot of a lot of information
it's also used by uh a number of
Medicaid enrolled providers to be able
to look at the status of certain
applications like for nursing facility
long-term care uh so that they can help
us help the client or their patient uh
in order to get uh a determination of
Eligibility as quickly as possible uh so
they're able to look at uh the accounts
with certain authorization from the
client to be able to to help with that
uh there are number of projects uh that
we've conducted in 24 and even more in
26 and I'd like to talk about those
um essentially serving 1100 Department
users uh and about a million
transactions every single
day there are a number of priority
projects that we're looking at including
some uh strategies that would reduce the
snap error rate which we were just
talking
about uh there are a number of projects
that we want to implement that would
actually enhance the user experience for
New Hampshire easy
uh to make it
easier uh there are a number of
operational efficiencies that we want to
be able to implement which I can talk
about uh as well what those priorities
are on the second slide uh slide
27 this is more specifically narrowed
down to the uh work that is uh being
built in new uh New Heights specifically
to support long-term supports and
services so we've added a number of
users to uh the system for that uh which
includes it support for uh case
management uh and services for the uh
choices for Independence Medicaid waiver
uh the um developmentally dis disabled
population uh acquired brain disorder uh
those waiver management uh uh activities
there's uh functionality in here now
that supports Adult Protective Services
uh and uh there number of additional
users and um are are these five bullets
mutually exclusive or or if you do like
one set of it upgrade you get all of
them in the same upgrade
packet are these distinct these These
are distinct separate functions of the
system now that
support thank you long-term support so
you have prioritizations within those
even yes all right
so and I wanted to touch on um so those
are you'll see the in the box there the
uh higher priority projects uh for the
the system that supports for example the
system of care uh for healthy aging uh
and a number of Medicaid projects a
number of them uh and some other
long-term care waiver
projects so this is also designed to
help support area agencies and other
stakeholders nursing facilities um
helping those clients those patients um
helping us to help
them so I'm just going to give you a
germ of a thought if if if if if this
conversation continues around migrating
long-term service support to
mcos that that that may have
implications for how you prioritize
these particular projects um you know
maybe hold hold off on the long-term
care a little
longer um I I I I don't know I don't I
don't know what to do with that but I
just want to let you know that there has
been discussion about sure and I think
that uh Dr Hardy can provide you with
quite a bit more detail and information
specific to uh the long-term care
supports and services work and how that
is being impacted with what uh changes
we're making for them in New Heights
okay
what's critical in these last few slides
because I'd like to give the public an
opportunity if anyone so I do want to
talk about just for uh briefly if I can
the priority areas that we're looking at
specifically for BFA or the Bureau of
family assistance uh and uh the business
models that we're currently using we're
really identifying the impact of
operations here by looking at process
people and systems there are significant
number of Demands there are a lot of
challenges in this Bureau to meet them
so how can we leverage uh changing
certain models of how we do business so
for example changing from a case based
model processing model to a task based
processing model so I'll talk about that
uh very briefly but we're basically just
recognizing where the challenges are in
the each of these processes sure so I
like this slide a lot uh I can relate to
this uh I see the source is deoe
uh is is
a uh are are are the de deoe people
essential to this effort yes they're
essentially conducting uh quite an
analysis uh for us um in order to help
us determine what changes we may want to
pursue are are you all able to hire one
or two or three really great people in
the department and and do with less Deo
service deo's pretty expensive well um
they're great quality yeah and and this
is work that Deo has been partnering
with us on um to try to look towards the
future of what it is that we may be able
to do whether it's low hanging fruit uh
low or no cost items that we would CH
look towards changing or more complex or
higher cost items that we would look
towards changing so this is a very early
stage of looking at uh a comparison of
what other states are doing yeah uh and
seeing where they are successful and
what's not working in other particular
States so they're bringing us all of
this information so this started this
slide is July 24 so we've got eight
months a run rate already with
deoe okay and you're starting to feel
like you're already seeing results well
we are seeing basically uh identifying
what it is that we could prioritize as
far as changing
based on funding that we may have uh and
the complexity what is the level of
effort needed for any of the things that
are are recommended so we've we've uh
quite a list from them uh that we are
trying to prioritize right now um but
because we're so chronically underst
staffed um and have identified uh you
know really where it is that we want to
uh where it is we need to make some
particular changes that would help
reduce our vacancy rate and help make
training easier uh But it includes
further autom automation uh to align
with that business model yeah um and I
know that you heard from Mr weers a bit
about uh implementing AI in some
instances and this is an area that we're
looking at for that specifically limited
to policies looking at real-time
information for staff so I feel like uh
I'm jamming you on time here as you're
reaching the conclusion and so like
earlier when we said that we would try
to find another division 3 work session
to bring your slide back on the item
four of the tanif if if you go home and
think about this and you go oh darn I
need another 15 minutes you know let's
let's let's let's put those two things
together and Tack it onto another
division three sure so so I can you can
you conclude I before you conclude
though is there anyone in the audience
who thinks they want to testify or say
something on this
subject so there are a couple of people
so um can you are you able to kind of
conclude with where we're at knowing
that that you can come back and nail The
Landing later well I I think that if
there are questions specifically to the
accounting units in this particular area
we would want time to be able to look at
that um but I I wanted to lay a bit of a
foundation so that you have an
understanding as to here are the
challenges this is what we're currently
doing about them and this is what I
would like your help with in the
future I think that prioritize needless
is fascinating and we just need to talk
about it and see if we've got a business
case that justifies the taxpayers
investment in the next budget because
cash is tight so so I I I'm I'm I I'm
I'm in a learning mode with you
excellent um Mr W do you have anything
you want to wrap up on here no not at
this point thank you though okay any uh
members have final questions before we
call the audience Mr representative
Daniels thank you this is a question for
Mr White uh throughout the
presentations uh I think every every
member on the committee has asked at one
time or another about the numbers on you
might go from zero to $3 million and
you've done a great job in
explaining where where it comes from um
unfortunately we I'd probably be here
another 3 hours if I I wrote down
everything that you said so as I go
through the budget what is the best way
for me when I see a figure that I don't
understand uh to be able to understand
that I know you had talked at one time
about not giving a whole uh whole budget
um listing of of the transfers um but I
also feel that it may not be the best
way to present you with 50 questions a
day sure um I I I I I agree I mean I
think the budget is a very difficult
opaque document um because it doesn't
say exactly what it means um I would
recommend if there's specific areas to
initially go through the LBA and and
start there and if if Kevin doesn't have
the answer I can I can work with Kevin
uh to get the correct answer for you and
we are working on those um those
crosswalks from uh the DCF presentation
that we had discussed and we should have
those for you here soon
representative Stringham welcome you
want to start at the top and go back
through or yeah can we can you just
repeat everything no thank you very much
um I I did have a I I was able to uh
review most participate in most of this
remotely um a question I had coming back
to the tanif question um was uh first of
all I wanted you to verify that the
spending for the this bium is adequate
to um uh maintain the tanif um funding
at the same level going forward and then
following up on that it sounded like you
have concerns uh that um that uh some of
the staff reductions is going to leave a
short intan of spending and that you're
I want to make sure I understood
properly that you're going to come back
to us uh uh during the budget process uh
with a with the tanif fully funded to
maintain uh the funding for uh the next
bium cycle and then I have one followup
question could could I ask you to
clarify that are I I heard two things in
there I think I think you want to
validate that we're on track to finish
this existing budget with the
appropriate match right and you're also
asking going forward what the risks are
associated with meeting in the next
budgets match that's exactly correct Mr
chair all right thank you sure so um I I
can't yet say for the current state
fiscal year um we are working uh the on
on the analysis so I've talked about the
budget system that we implemented um a
couple of years back that now allows us
in in real time to quickly be able to
determine that so that analysis is
ongoing probably need at least another
week and what the discussion that
occurred um earlier repres
representative Stringham while you were
not here was um relative to the
reduction of the 394 unfunded positions
and whether we'd be able to meet for
State fiscal years 26 and 27 um we're
we're looking at that same analysis
similar obviously for the future uh not
actual expense um but we're hoping here
in probably a week or two to have
something for the committee just so that
we can alert you of any concerns that
we've been able to identify so far okay
thank you and I guess the other question
I had is just you know are you seeing
signs that these unfunded
positions now you know currently
unfilled soon to be unfunded I guess
current budget unfunded positions are
making it difficult for you to keep up
uh with things like this kind of
calculations or compliance uh
requirements compliance reports uh and
you know things like you know accounting
or or whether uh whether you're seeing a
lot of stress and your side from that
thank you sure I I I think um again
there there's sort of two factors that
play number one is the state uh is under
a hiring freeze with the exception of
direct care positions and there's a
waiver process for the other positions
so that's sort of one side of the coin
so that's sort of that will naturally
slow down um hiring and then the other
side is um you know we anticipate that
the you know $26 million of General
funds or so um of unfunded positions
will have an impact in the future and
typically what you will see as a result
of of these things is slowly over time
your your vacancy rate will increase
because you won't necessarily have the
ility initially you won't see a lot but
it's it's sort of the slow cycle where
you can't maximize posting all your
positions at once cuz you you don't have
them funded um so you know we we we
would probably see the long-term effects
6 Months 8 months a year plus out in the
next bium where we would start to see uh
any any potential negative consequences
of that but I think at this point in
time it's still relatively
early okay well something that we may
talk about in future is just you know
want to understand the consequences of
the positions not being filled and
whether things like tanif funding will
be uh unnecessarily at risk so or what
we can do to avoid that thank
you thank
you anything further from committee
members any closing remarks with regards
to the division of economic
stability representative priest for
question just as a
clarification um there was a discussion
early on about the 73 unfunded
positions um and you just mentioned
another 26 can you just clarify that for
me
please um I I I had indicated 394
unfunded positions the 394 the 26 number
just back the envelope math from my
perspective um that's the general fund
in impact over the bium of unfund those
so a lot of our positions most of our
positions are not 100% generally funded
many have mixed funding um so when I've
just ran some quick numbers as far as
the general fund Financial impact to our
budget over the buum it equates to
roughly 26 million but I need to go back
and and just validate that um the reason
I mentioned that is it's more just in
terms of what is the what is the global
general fund impact and for from a
historical perspective for the for The
banum Mending June 30th of 2023 we had I
I think it was approximately $22.6
million Personnel back of the budget
reduction um during during that bium
that we managed uh through but we did
see those vacancy rates slowly tick up
during that
process okay thank
you okay closing remarks
well thank you both very much once again
a very well prepared
presentation uh quite a few follow-up
items so hopefully we'll get to those
and uh if there's anything else I'm sure
we'll be in touch thank you thank you
thank
you so we'll just give our guests a
moment to clear out their desk but those
who are in the audience if you could
prepare yourselves to come and testify
make sure to clearly state your name who
you
represent and will eagerly await what
you have to
say welcome to division three house
finance committee this is the work
session on the division of economic
stability thank you so much thank you to
all the committee members for the
opportunity to provide comments my name
is Trina Engle finger I am the early
care and education policy coordinator at
new Futures which is a nonpartisan
nonprofit organization that works on
matters relating to health and
well-being in New
Hampshire and and I just want to briefly
address uh the committee's questions
around costs and benefits and return on
investment specific to the child care
scholarship
program um broadly I just want to note
that what makes investment in child care
programming quite unique is that it
really is an investment in child
development in child care businesses in
the state's
Workforce and also in the state's
economy as a whole and just to be a
little bit more specific about economic
impacts uh there was a report just last
month from the New Hampshire fiscal
policy Institute that really
underscored how much money is lost due
to child care shortages in the state and
just in terms of State impact alone it
ran to the tens of Millions per
year and the child care scholarship
program is a key scaffold a stabilizing
influence in our child care
infrastructure and that same report from
New Hampshire fiscal policy Institute
noted that every dollar invested in
subsidy programs like the child care
scholarship can yield more than a dollar
in economic impacts in the year that it
is invested so just wanted to underscore
those points I think uh that that report
has been shared with the committee I'd
be happy to share it if it hasn't um but
as the department made clear in its
presentation These funds are also more
than matched by federal contributions so
it's a very cost-effective program and
um new Futures appreciates and strongly
supports the Departments and the
governor's budget maintaining and uh
supporting funding for the scholarship
program
thank you so
much thank you very much for being here
I do have a question and if it this may
be um off topic but if you don't know
just say Senate Bill
404 last year are you familiar that
certainly yeah okay uh for those on the
committee so that passed last year
representative walner was a co-sponsor
it's relative to expanding Child Care
Professionals eligibility for the child
care scholarship program my question is
uh have you seen a difference with the
passage of that bill or any comments now
that we're a year out from the passage
of that Bill thank you so much for the
question um I'm certainly not an expert
but I have been monitoring closely the
roll out of that bill I think that um
there hasn't been a lot of time because
the actual implementation only started
in
January and so um it's difficult to see
the impacts in recruitment and and
retention in such a short time without a
lot of data to gather but certainly have
heard from some of the participants that
it was a game Cher for them in terms of
allowing them to remain in the child
care
Workforce thank you very much appreciate
that any other questions for Miss Engle
finger is that correct yes thank
you all right all set thank you very
much
thanks and next if you could just again
state your name and who you represent
clearly and we're
ready good afternoon how do you do I'm
Jackie Cowell from Early Learning New
Hampshire um I'm delighted to meet you
and talk with you today uh my uh
conversation today uh Trina did a great
job uh telling you about you're getting
it I had the chance to email you
yesterday didn't if you had a chance to
see it hi thank you um wanted to make
sure you had this uh report and also
have a specific request so um I really
like chairman Edward's question about
prioritized needs is it can you make the
business case is this you know use good
use of taxpayers investing money and so
this is really what I'd like to talk to
you about and so without going over all
the key points which you saw in the
email but again as Trina also mentioned
hundreds of millions of dollars
um are lost here in New Hampshire both
tax and local and state tax revenue
families earnings um businesses um
returns and losses based on the child
care shortage so as you might recall in
2023 very much on a bipartisan basis
there was a $15 million investment very
specifically to retain and recruit the
childcare Workforce and so not only did
the the legislature passed that in 2023
they also put in hb2 a directive that
DHHS included in its next banian budget
2627 and they did they did include 15
million 7 a half each year and so uh in
the Govern in the uh in the governor's
budget that was taken out and uh as I
mentioned uh that's on page
881 of the budget at the bottom of the
page you'll see a $15 million in our
current bium and then a zero going
forward and so what I'm here uh hoping
to talk with you about is again not only
is it a cost of you know are we going to
save money by doing this how critical
that is but I believe we can also find a
way together by looking at what are some
of the allowable funding sources to be
used for this we did use General funds
in the current bium and of course
understand the worry about the uh
balancing a budget so really want to
work with you to see is there a way we
can put it back you know that 7 and a
half million a year I really feel is a
you know such a smart investment and
love to work with you and find what are
we believe there are some allowable
sources very specifically that could be
used for this so we ask that you
consider restoring it maintaining that
investment and we'd love to work with
you thank you do you by chance have the
section of the previous house bill to
related to I will make sure to send it
to you yes be glad to send that to you
great thank you you're welcome any
questions for M Cowell sorry oh I did
forget to mention something if I may and
that is many states across the country
did invest in giving extra supports to
the workforce and again why is this
government's role well certainly we all
know parents are spending so much more
for child care that they can currently
afford M making sure that the Workforce
of of child care gets sufficient money
and has incentives to stay that cannot
be born by the parents the hardworking
parents that are using it and so those
states that have invested many are
continuing that investment Beyond um the
the pandemic Etc all of our three um
states that border us have continued
their investment in a childcare
Workforce support and
incentive yeah understood represent of
Daniels for a question yeah thank you do
do you have any kind of a document that
would uh show the the the success or or
the failure of the uh of the 15 million
that was given thank you for that
question the um it just went out in
August so even though it was passed in
23 it was uh distributed in August of
2024 so it's just beginning but um I do
believe there was an interim report that
um the department was was gathering on
some of that which I don't have a copy
of but I'll see what we can do to find
out it has just started we have
anecdotal data certainly that people um
felt it was not only a monetary thing
which of course is important but it's
the recognition of the importance of
their work that meant a lot to the Child
Care Professionals
yeah okay looks like we're all set thank
you very much thank you
any further comments from those in the
room or out of the room all
right looks like we're all set for today
I do just want to remind everybody that
we are back here tomorrow Tuesday March
4th at 10: a.m We have scheduled and
published a budget work session for the
division of Public Health Services
that's next on the division three agenda
uh do be taking notes as we go along
here so much material and so much to
take in and uh as we go along it's good
to uh earmark various things that may be
of interest or amended later on or
highlighted or discussed at another time
anything further from members of
division
3 and that'll do it we are going to
close the work session on economic
stability thank you
all e